I would argue and I agree and I think you end up just losing your mind and see
what we're going live.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Too
much ladies and mother.
Fucking gentle man.
Yeah.
What's up boys,
man,
we're live now.
Other people can hear all the Shit we've been saying.
Right?
It's hard to make the transition.
What do with live?
Fuck it.
We'll do it.
We'll do it live to go from an yeah,
that what was that hard copy or something like that.
He was on bill O'Reilly's.
Just freaking out.
It's a blowhard.
It's so amazing that that guy's popular board though,
right?
It's kind of dying down a towel.
Maybe guys like you,
but you weren't watching the first place.
If you're an old lady,
if you post Menopausal Olay below,
right?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
he's very crowd.
He's really easy.
It's like he creates,
he's like a sharp profile.
Right?
So he,
when he'll,
he'll make the issues really cut and dry and really loud and here the lines,
it goes in,
the tide goes out.
You can explain that.
There you go.
God,
I'm putting my money on.
God.
I read two of his books and I read two of Ann Coulter's books to see what they
were saying and it was really interesting because I know why they're popular.
If you,
if you package something in terms of good guys,
bad guys,
or you know,
like he wrote a book called who's looking out for you.
It was kind of an interesting book about,
and he was very real about saying,
look,
I run in a circle of people that are really wealthy and powerful.
Guess what?
They don't really care about you because that's how human beings are when they
have a lot of stuff going on in Donald Trump.
Makes it a little bit,
your boy,
Donald Trump's kind of flying off the hinges.
I think he's just saying,
not my boy.
Well,
yeah,
he is.
He's your best friend.
I think he's just saying it for like x factor.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's just trying to stand out.
He's wild as fuck.
Yeah,
he's an EGOMANIAC.
When my buddy Jimmy Burke met Donald Trump,
he said,
Donald,
huge fan,
huge fan of your buildings.
I think your buildings are amazing,
dude.
And I love your tie
with the Donald say,
just kind of looked at him,
killed Teddy Demi at the time who was the director of the late Teddy.
Damien just went,
ah,
okay,
thanks.
He goes,
but look at your tie.
He kept saying your tie.
It's like,
you know,
so when you're building,
the sponsors have dropped them so many after you made those comments about
Mexicans and rape.
Yeah,
he's in home.
He's retarded.
And Anderson,
Anderson Cooper was like,
you know,
financially,
how much money have you lost?
He goes,
I don't know.
I'm Brits really don't care.
I just don't care.
Merge Merv Griffin,
Merv Griffin.
I did.
Uh,
I did a show with him once and Merv Griffin was insanely rich as we know.
And he also wrote like,
he was also an artist.
Like he wrote the theme song to jeopardy and Weird Shit.
And you know more if you know Merv Griffin this,
you might be a little young.
I don't know who he is.
I know the theme.
You just thought the name.
And he wrote,
he wrote the theme song to a bunch of different shows.
And when you do that,
it's a slick move that you get paid every time it plays.
And there are a lot of examples of those kinds of things that he did.
He was,
he could play the piano and I'm think,
but he was also a major mogul,
like a tycoon and wealthier than Donald Trump.
Ferociously gay
him.
Yes.
So ferociously gate.
Did a show with,
with his company Trigram your dog?
No.
He was very friendly,
but there was a,
does it look in his eyes?
Like the door's always open.
Harvest.
I spent,
he's just like a guy.
I spent a week with him.
Hold on,
stop.
We're going to take him to his pizza.
You wearing flip flops and he massage your feet.
Honestly,
I spend a lot of time blindfolded.
I can't remember.
I can't remember a lot of that,
but he was like my dad and aunt and uncle at the same time.
Bill Cosby was there and he,
he,
uh,
and I said,
what do you,
how do you like run this empire?
You know,
cause he,
he found,
he created like,
here's where I found Ryan Seacrest's and putting him on.
He owns all these companies.
They really,
yes.
And he's got a radio.
Would Ryan was,
I was,
did Ryan show way back?
He was on the radio.
He still does radio to see Chris has $100 million.
That motherfucker gets up every morning and does the radio from six to nine in
crazy work ethic and crazy work and listen to it.
It's almost like they're not human.
Yeah.
It's like the people that call aren't human and he's not human.
It's like a different species.
He's so nonthreatening.
He's so exactly.
You know,
what's your favorite color?
I,
he's another guy.
I ride booze.
Great.
Next color.
What's your favorite color?
Like?
No,
no,
no man.
There's no man on him.
All of robot.
Just Jamie from California.
What's your favorite food?
That's how it is.
No memories.
He's another guy I spent a week with.
Always in a suit.
What the fuck?
You guys weren't sort of for him.
I did this TV show where they're hosted and it's called,
it's called Bank of Hollywood.
I don't want to talk about it.
And he's in a suit.
He was always in a suit and I would try that one too,
right?
Yes.
He looked good.
He's a small guy.
Very small.
About 130 and one 35 about it.
And I didn't show when he had a talk show,
I didn't think he was that light.
I think you're exaggerating.
No,
five seven one 35 I give him,
I took him in.
You know you don't mean you did spend a week with them.
You already know.
You know how I take a man in,
I'll take a man in visually and even physically it's too much.
Yeah,
I'm pretty good at that stuff.
And he,
he ended up,
I said it was inside eight.
Yeah.
There you go.
Look at you.
I don't want to talk about that.
He's five.
He's five,
eight talent.
You hosted a show and how it's running secrets not the host and you were the
host.
Well cause he was producing it and they paid me a lot of money for just to do
for one day to do four episodes.
And I was like all right.
And then I have the option to get out and then I,
I called my agent,
I got good,
didn't it go well?
I didn't like what it was.
I don't listen.
It was people basically asking for money and I was duped into thinking it was
Morgan to be like a talk soup thing.
And the minute I got there they said we want to turn it into more of a talk
show.
And I said that's not what I do.
I don't want to do that.
Blah Blah Blah.
A talk show.
Yeah,
they kinda hit me.
Literally when I got there I thought it was going to be like I was going to be
doing a lot of comedy,
kind of a talk soup thing.
It funny and that's how they presented it to me and that's how the audition was.
And I got there and they all of a sudden they go,
we want you to wear a suit and just kind of read the teleprompter.
And I went and bought your stuff.
Yeah.
But I made a lot of money for a day and I tried to make connection with Ryan
Seacrest is a guy and he's just so professional.
He's just kind of one of those guys where he went.
I said,
how you doing man?
He's like,
you know,
I had made $13 million a year.
He's a robot.
I went,
so what are you up to man?
He's your Stengel and stuff.
He goes,
having a lot of fun,
having a lot of fun and that was all I could get out of.
There was no detail he's on.
It was just,
he wasn't willing to give those guys,
man.
Yeah,
we may not know who he is.
Your favorite color,
Brendan?
I'm like calm.
It's just you and me,
man.
Who gives a fuck?
Purple's a good color.
I think you'd look good in purple.
Okay.
Caller number three.
Like what?
My feet hurt.
Low feet can hurt.
All right.
It's so most of this has to getting nowhere with this.
This is what I tell.
You know what I mean?
Like he found a frequency.
He found like a,
there's a station in the dial that was available and it's a low hum and he's
easy to be stuck there and you're not going to get any fucking craziness out of
him and you're not going to get the wife smacking.
You're not going to get any fucking drunk driving.
You're not going to get any heroin.
He's a robot.
I would suck my Dick.
That's an impediment.
Even as description that he found a frequency
and it's like hosting American idol hosting,
like come on morning radio,
all raw and we're going to give away a free donut.
Like a Casey case of offense.
I'll ride.
I love donuts too.
We'll take the next caller.
It's like you got a role like the,
like the Truman show where the rest of the world like what the fuck are you
doing Tuesday?
It's Tuesday.
It's donut.
Tuesdays.
Everybody.
Yeah,
he's an odd dude.
But he used to be more um,
more fuck around d on the radio when,
when he used to do radio show,
I did his radio show up way,
way,
way back in the day before he was famous and he was more fuck around.
She was more controversial but that was what happened was he hit the fucking
mother load of money with American idol.
Remember is to host and they got one,
I think one guy left and he stayed and then American idol blew up.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a mom.
People like him and he works hard.
Oh,
he's a,
he's a work horse sona now.
Right?
Like you have a persona.
You got to keep that all the time.
He's that hum.
Fuck that.
I was getting high.
Nothing low.
Nothing crazy.
Not a way to live.
Well not for me or you can't be my friend.
See chaos it do.
I need a little self destruction so you don't have nothing.
I wonder why that is.
Why do we look,
I might kindred spirits are dudes like that.
The minute I hear there's like a little,
like a little fucking darkness.
I'm like,
well,
there we go.
Sorry.
I'm a little darkness with some construction.
Yeah,
I mean it's one of the things that we hit off with right away.
I was like,
oh,
I can trust this guy.
Yes.
Circle just as retarded,
but you could tell me anything.
I'd be like,
I understand.
Like literally I got to hide this body
color's red,
man.
That's fucking weird.
You see,
you see this guy who used to go to the boxing gym and I worked out at,
and he was gay,
but he didn't want to admit he was gay.
And uh,
he would,
uh,
tell us about stories about girls and it was one of the most bizarre thing.
So I was like,
man,
it was like a on this dance floor man.
This girl came up to me and you know,
just a totally just started making out with me and I was like,
hey,
back off.
Like what the fuck?
It's like,
well damn,
why the fuck did you say?
I remember in high school there was this guy,
this guy used to get a lot of girls in high school.
I remember one time he said,
I like to kiss girls,
and then when they tried to touch my chest I say,
no,
I'm not ready for that because if they do that to me,
I do that to them and I remember I was like,
you saw the enemy
can't speak to anymore.
There's some guys,
especially like foreign guys,
I have some,
a lot of friends from England where you'll be like,
yeah,
I hooked up with this girl,
man.
She was a freak to all of us.
It's like,
oh cool man.
We know what that means though.
British guys like,
yeah,
what she do,
what exactly she do.
Well,
hey man,
she's a freak.
Sort of start making out.
Did you talk to you guys?
You immediately stop fucking he wear a condom or no condom.
What?
What happens with the coach to come somewhere?
Yeah,
the boxing gym.
The way I described it as like,
like I don't know how to speak French,
but if you told me the words to say,
I could say them but I do,
wouldn't know what the fuck I was saying.
Great way of describing as a gay man trying to pretend he's straight and he was
saying all the stuff that you,
you mean sorta.
I know he's talking about being with a girl making out.
I was like,
wait,
what?
It was all off.
It was like poly vous Francais it's off man.
I don't even know if you know you're saying.
Yeah.
That's so true.
The small of her back,
man,
when my hand Corinne's it's very,
it's very important to be able to trust dudes.
We were talking about that one football player was on,
what's that show we were talking about where they were like,
what's the most attractive part of a woman?
And I've always thought this guy was gay and he's at the buzzer.
He's like,
Eh,
her feet.
And everyone was like,
[inaudible]
you sir.
I was like,
oh no.
Do before before him was like them big ass titties,
40 3004 1000 Jim,
me,
my answer would be I'd bang her if she didn't have feet.
So not that important to me.
You know,
my girl could have talent,
I would have no idea.
I don't give a fuck.
Right.
Just covering them up with a cloth,
but we'll figure it out.
You got it.
You can have of hobbit feet.
I don't know,
czar there.
The whole crowd was like,
damn,
it just ruined the whole show.
You're lying about your life.
All right.
Back to being treat on the feet.
I just fuck her and stare at her feet.
Put them in my mouth,
dude.
Sometimes there's those portals with these dudes are getting jacked up his feet.
My old girlfriend gun,
I had a girlfriend.
It's how many she's date data guy who I knew who used to put her feet in his
mouth when he was having sex and I was like always jealous boy.
Maybe.
Maybe,
maybe you like that and that's the one thing I don't do for you.
I never,
I never thought he would put her foot and yes ma'am.
Yeah,
it's not too.
She told you about that though.
What?
Wanting you to do it?
Well,
my Dick was in my hand.
No,
I,
yeah,
I don't know shit she did with other dudes.
Of course.
That's what I get in deep into that stuff.
I'm very curious and uh,
and I knew him and she said that he would put his,
he loved her feet and he'd put her entire foot in his mouth.
I was like,
well first of all,
I don't think I could do that.
Yeah.
Something deep throat.
Anyways,
back to Merv Griffin.
Merv Griffin was my friend went to have lunch at his house and he had just
hottest shit young dudes serving all over his mansion.
Just like the best look in suicide pieces.
Smoothed freeways.
Yeah.
Just well-groomed,
muscled,
beautiful young men.
If you're a young gay dude that the has to be the line.
He was about 65 at the time.
Young Gay Gay dudes period.
There's,
there's something to be said for that life because first of all,
they don't have kids unless they really want to.
They have to go out of their way to have the beast.
So they have all this money.
Right.
Cause they don't,
they have total disposable income.
Exactly.
Most of them don't have dudes they have to take care of.
And last.
They like older guys that are like hanging on and they have like these younger
dudes that don't have any money.
Liberace style.
So exactly.
They just guys,
there's always that one couple of young guys take the car keys.
There's always the young twinks who were into the older dudes into older dudes.
They're just not into working.
Yeah,
they're not in the work.
You said they get plowed.
You get a word,
you don't work this day.
You know it's not a nine to five but you clocking in on these nuts.
You know what I'm saying?
It will be some work.
You're going to get that work in an app at all the time.
Mother fucker
wake up with these old balls anytime they want.
They have deals.
They have to,
I don't want any lip.
No back doc can talk to mass moca.
When I won my Dick Suck.
This is no,
no conversation sucked a dick.
I remember I heard of a girl,
she was applying for a job out here at a doctor office and it was like an
assistant job and the doctor had in the contract that you have to give him a
blow job certain time during the day.
Ooh,
Shit.
Tight move doc.
That's some shit.
C'Mon got a contract contract written into the contract.
You know what I,
you know what that may be that be real.
I don't know this
very recent.
No,
that girl could sue that guy so easily.
Yeah,
maybe that's a girl
that's a girl.
Make a story up and she wants you to play doctor doctor with you,
Bro.
Well,
I had her sign the contract.
I'm not a doctor.
White lab coat.
Yeah.
I proclaimed myself of doctor.
I'm a doctor now
three and a level of expertise.
I'm a doctor of dark jokes.
Sign this.
So ridiculous.
The idea that that could be true.
I mean in my picture,
I just don't imagine that you can,
I don't think that you can make that a contract.
A girl would like maybe a picture of that.
Maybe it's like a deal.
You know what I'm saying?
That's prostitution.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just don't think it's slow.
Like I don't think you can have a sexual calm down somewhere around here.
I don't think you're allowed to have a sexual contract that would be binding.
Yeah,
because I think that like it would be considered prostitution though.
May.
Maybe.
Maybe the major you'd act.
Yes.
He says favors at 3:00 PM oh favors,
favors,
physical favors.
Physical errands.
I don't even think you could like put in a regular way.
I guess you could put in like you have to rub my back.
Yeah.
You can just be like,
Hey,
listen,
uh,
everything looks good here.
We agree on this.
The deal is,
you know,
it's on the contract,
but Friday's at three o'clock.
You need to suck this day.
Take a look at this.
This is a woman alive that wanted to guy to eat her pussy every Friday at three
o'clock.
I'm sure there's some thirsty doctors.
Female Dog,
49 right?
Yeah.
Divorced having nothing for like six shit.
If I didn't have this pocket as I thought I was going to have to start doing
that shit.
Fucking yeah,
I'll do it Friday.
We'll suck it.
Three will suck in the afternoon.
I will suck your titties at two o'clock but in the old days,
I'm sure they had contracts like that but low the we'll all laws against sexual
harassment.
I just passing the laws now.
Fucking laws fucking up everything man.
Back in the day.
Just the idea that you would have that in the contract.
Well marriage in marriage is not binding.
You don't have to,
you don't have to have sex in a mirror,
you know it's up to it's given.
Right,
right.
Well it's not though because we all know guys that don't do anything there.
They have a marriage with a,
yeah,
they have a roommate and they take care of their kids together.
We both know a quite a few families like that and we'll get together.
Brian and I will get the feeling of what the fuck cause they'll tell you like we
haven't had sex in a year and we got in in two years.
My buddy.
Amazing to me.
My Buddy,
uh,
was poor most of his life.
Okay.
I mean like the most he had ever made as an actor was like $40,000 a year.
That was like his best year.
Then he got a television show immediately after the television.
Joe,
his wife divorced him and now she wants for the next,
because they'd been married for 10,
she wants for the next five years,
half of what he was making when he was on the television show and alimony and
like the tough,
first of all,
everybody who,
if you get a television show you if you're lucky as fuck.
Yeah.
It goes a year.
If you're lucky as save that money,
if you're crazy lucky,
it goes two years.
If you hit to a show,
you get a show that's on syndication.
Oh my God.
How many people get to a show that's on city?
Very few.
She ignored all the years that they were together,
all the years where they go,
that he was struggling like more than 10 years.
She ignored all ignore those years concentrated only on the one year that he was
on a sitcom and wanted half of that money.
So his Simpson ship,
man,
he had a kid,
we freaked the fuck out.
It was weird.
It was very hard for him because they are hard cause you have to maintain that
lifestyle.
Right?
Yeah.
That's the idea.
The idea that he was supposed to maintain her lifestyle and he was,
uh,
he was,
it was really hard because he has a son and he loves his kid and he wasn't
having sex with his wife.
He hadn't had sex with her for over a year.
Say that to me is already like,
there are so many people that ignore that major elephant in the room.
Sex.
Yeah man,
if you're married but you trying to get me to cheat on you,
right.
I mean if we're not having sex,
what do you think's going to happen?
But then that never is like,
I know two people who are in marriage is like that and they don't really discuss
that.
And I'm always like,
how are you living your life this way,
man?
Yeah.
How are you?
It's the same guys too.
Like when I was back in Denver,
my buddies,
I was like,
Hey,
let's go out and like,
Oh man,
what should we tell him?
What should I tell him?
Like girl,
like what?
Tell your fucking going out man.
Like I know,
but we got come up with a plan.
I'm like,
what's the fucking plan man?
Just tell him we're going to go out.
They're all like worried.
Yeah,
it's the same guys,
man.
It's weird.
But you got me thinking about being an actor.
Like could you talk about if you'd had to just rely on fighting,
making a living.
I really feel that way about acting like thank God for the podcast and stand up.
I can't imagine having to worry about making my living as an actor and guess
what?
I work as an actor.
Well the [inaudible] a confining thing with you,
like your best,
you're at your best like on podcasts or doing stand up cause you're free.
You can be you like no one is ever going to write you correctly.
They'll write a character version that you'll do your best to try to spice up.
But also you need their approval.
You need to be cast.
Do you need to be a part of like a,
a cast of people?
You need to get along with everybody.
You got to get to the set when they say you got to do all those things are
against what you are.
Well you are as is weird free spirit of grew up all over the world and you know,
you,
you kind of were on your own a little bit too much and see you made friends in
weird ways and see developed as fucking crazy personality.
But it translates as into funny.
It's a fucking go willy Wonka golden ticket to Willy Wonka golden ticket to
funny.
But that is this like it's like a side job and people get stuck in that side
job.
[inaudible] you should go on a bunch of auditions.
I got a crazy story.
Sorry,
I didn't mean go back to you.
I just want to know a lot dishes is the only two auditions I ever went on when I
was,
uh,
when I first started doing,
like the acting thing.
I've got the TV shows.
Yup.
The only two I ever went on a show called hardball.
Got It.
And then show called news radio.
Are those the only two auditions I ever did and he got both.
I got Bolton.
How rare is that?
It's impossible.
It doesn't make sense.
It's,
see Ya,
I have two shows.
I went to syndication,
that's insane.
Anyone on addition?
And the director asked me to do it in a different way and he goes,
you can't,
you can call me right after.
And he goes,
you know what?
Nah,
well aren't you?
You're skinny lane.
Rd Lang was in the movie and there's the only reason why I was willing to do in
the first place.
So it was going to do with rd.
Right.
And the guy goes,
all right,
I read it as you know,
prepared.
And then he goes,
okay,
if the,
it was a little annoying to hear like pompous English guy and he goes,
okay,
well I want you to do now is you all trying to get him very interested in being
married?
Okay,
you'll married and you're going to write this down on a piece of paper.
Here's a,
here's a pen,
here's a marker,
and you're going to,
you're going to write,
just married and you get a hold it up like you're going,
you're trying to convince him that you want him to be married.
I go,
listen,
first of all,
I'm not,
I'm not acting,
I'm not sitting here talking to Artie Lange.
Okay?
I'm talking to a pa who could barely read the dude,
barely could read.
I mean he was reading it like,
like Floyd Mayweather.
Do you think it's a good thing for us to be out like this at night?
Fuck you.
Is it a good thing?
Come on man,
I go have fun.
You know,
so I'm supposed to be convincing this guy that marriage is the key to him.
I want you to buy just married.
Don't this piece of paper.
I go,
if we were on the set and you wanted me to help write your movie,
you wanted me to help make the movie better.
I would ad lib a whole scene where I say just married.
I go,
but I'm,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
Not here.
I go,
we're in a conference room.
No,
I got,
this is a PA.
I go,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
Like this is what do you,
what?
What the fuck is he just peaced out?
Yeah.
I said I won't do this now.
And I left.
It was the last time you were out did I think?
No,
I did Kevin James Movies.
But uh,
but I only did it cause I like Kevin,
but uh,
they,
my agent called me up.
You can't do that.
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
What do you mean I can't do,
I didn't want to do it.
Don't tell me I can't do that.
I think you're one of the only guys who can pull that off.
Right.
I couldn't pull it off.
I didn't pull it off.
I didn't get the role.
I tanked out.
Yeah,
but that personality trait is what got you to where you were like,
no,
I'm a maybe.
Maybe it was hard to be an actor though with that personality trait because
what?
I agree it's such a collaborative effort.
No,
I knew,
I could see through the,
through the fucking looking glass that this was an unbelievable steaming log of
a movie.
It was up,
but you don't want to be associated with I do.
You want to,
I felt it coming.
I knew it was coming.
I had already done a bad sitcom when I did that hardball show.
It was a bad sitcom and it started off good.
But all these fucking people got involved
and the original writers were really funny guys that were on the Simpsons and
married with children.
But then again,
all these fucking like professional hack guys who make these hacky sitcoms and
they'd make jokes like they,
they ruined it,
write jokes and I been there before and it's hell you would think it's like,
it's easier to work a job than it is to work a show where like it could be funny
and it turns out to be awful cause you're so conflicted as a comic when you know
something is really bad,
it's like I need to know funny.
You'll know if it was different than like getting paid to work at the fucking,
uh,
lumber yard,
you know,
carrying logs.
But it paid you 25 grand a week.
You'd be like,
oh well you know,
or a Sitcom the pays 25 grand a week.
But it's terrible.
I swear to God it's better to carry the logs.
Fuck that.
Cause the logs don't make you feel bad after.
It's,
if you don't feel like you're selling your soul well,
you know,
you're like,
you're just working.
You key into that.
Like I had like I had to really have a talk with myself.
I came out here to be an actor 20 years.
I studied it for years and I love by it.
I'm doing a show now,
I the other day and I said,
I was talking to my mother and I said,
I've never been on a set as an actor where I wasn't looking forward to it being
over like I was.
Yes.
Now think about that some in my whole life I worked really hard at being an
actor.
I really did have.
I been successful moderately,
but I worked hard at it and spend a lot of time in traffic going on auditions.
It's been a lot of anxiety trying to get jobs.
Sometimes I got him.
Most of the time I didn't,
but I want to have landed big jobs.
I've never been on a set where I was where I couldn't wait for it to be over.
Did you wake up excited though?
Nope,
I sure.
Why the fuck do it well,
that's why I do podcasts and stand up now and when I go on some auditions and
nice sound,
I listened for wonder woman.
Haven't heard back from Patty.
She should get it.
I felt I loved them when Abbot Kinney grabbing lunch and you're like,
fuck,
I should be an audition.
What do you mean?
When?
When you might have an audition coming up the way.
Oh,
and I forgot all.
Fuck,
and I forgot.
You just like,
fuck it.
I love that.
Let's cause everything's going well.
Look,
you're great at being Brian Count.
That's the real problems.
The best.
That's what I'm good at.
I'm doing good at hitting me,
man.
You're going to be in you.
You know,
like there's something in that and they can't,
you can't manufacture that.
No.
Tried.
I've tried.
I've cried on auditions where I've cried and a very dramatic scene and I got
seven people I don't know,
looking at me and I'm fucking crying but doing the lines and I'm fucking good.
Didn't get it.
But still I'm walking out wiping my tears.
They're like,
Brian,
you have very fine actor.
I'm like,
thank you very much.
Know.
I think that's the character.
It's the honors went home.
Part of me dying inside is nothing wrong with really enjoying that.
Like my friend Stephen Root from Newsweek,
right actor,
who's a great
actor.
He's been in the medical boardwalk.
Camba fantastic guy.
He's been in boardwalk empire office space,
a million different movies.
That guy is hilarious and he's always working and he loves becoming a new
character.
He loves it.
He has a craft so people love it.
Bradley Cooper and Bradley Cooper love lasting more than anything like was an
actor's studio and obsessed over little details about the character and how his
shirt is.
Listen man,
that's why he can do Americans timer.
Do you need those guys go?
Well,
there's the same thing and fighting too.
There's some guys who love that shit.
It's like the D as mothers love to be in the thick of things getting hit in the
face.
How feral Dosantos this guy.
See,
can we say officially you're done.
You're done.
Officially say it.
Don't listen to him.
Listen to me.
It's over.
Devil Angel.
No kidding.
Listen,
dude,
you you.
If you don't like making a lot of money talking and doing what comes naturally.
And if you'd rather go in there and get punched in the face by monsters,
please,
whatever you want.
I'm just here to support whatever decision you make.
Take a deep breath and don't say anything.
You know what the thing is?
I'm not officially doing anything for me it's just,
uh,
you know,
things are going so good.
It's just like,
you know,
and with the Reebok deal and all that stuff,
I just don't like the direction that it's going.
It doesn't make sense to me.
So I'm just going to keep doing what I'm doing and he's going to suck down 85
there,
I assume to down in one seven kitchen,
just like dead dead.
Could you imagine what you would look like at one seven that you would be a
skeleton but it doesn't have to put them in a drama that has been a medically
induced coma for five months.
This is a good point to talk about because now that they're,
um,
the new standards,
the new testing standards,
they're not allowing ivs anymore.
Fucking stupid.
Explain that to me.
Well,
because you could blood dope,
so they're checking,
they're checking for interest,
all levels of plastic,
but it's dangerous when you do that because it takes,
they say almost seven days to fully hydrate yourselves the way they were when
you were drinking.
And like with an IFE,
you can hydrate much faster traumas way more likely when you're dehydrated and
you don't have time in 24 hours to drink yourself hydrated.
I think they're taking it too far now they're taking a little too far,
but is there an argument to be made for the fact that they're just going to cut
out weight cutting now and that would be better for everybody or would they
never cut out weight cutting when people take a chance and fight dehydrated
dudes are always going to cut weight.
Do you know Andy Foster?
He's the director of the California State Athletic Commission.
Any foster is the,
as far as I'm concerned,
he's the most hard line guy.
He's a guy who has been involved in martial arts for a long time.
He's fought and he's a real fan.
And if fucking smart guy and he runs a tight ship,
California's tight,
tight shit.
I love this guy.
I love what he's doing.
But he suspended Sheila Manco for three fucking years or steroids,
right?
Sheila Manco pissed hot.
He suspended him for three years.
He essentially canceled his career like 100%.
Dan,
you think that's fair?
Know there's a debate.
I mean,
I don't know.
I,
part of me goes,
I like the fact that he takes a hard line,
that people can't do steroids anymore,
but another flag,
like this guy doesn't have a chance now he can't even get off of them.
But he can,
he can get out of California and fight.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
he can fight in like China.
You should fight in China.
You can go to fuck.
Yeah,
he's got a contract with [inaudible].
I don't even think you can do that.
Like that's the Vandelay Silva thing.
Like when Vandelay Silva ran away from the task,
which by the way,
Vandelay Silva was exonerated.
He got,
uh,
the,
the bank gave him a lifetime ban in California though,
but the court decided that that was an invalid.
You can't do that,
which is great.
She retire anyways.
He should retire.
Evangelist had some crazy wars and he's an all time,
all time legends.
But if I had to say like my favorite fighters,
the fight fighters that like when they're about to fight and I went,
whew.
Vandelays around 2% top top of the list.
When you saw the annually Silva fight and pride,
you saw some fucking chaos.
By the time I got to see him fight live,
it was already he was facing.
Yeah.
Damn Bro.
What he had to do.
That tissue completely flattened.
Yeah.
But his face was,
the scar tissue was so bad in his eyebrows that he would just get nicked and it
would just open up a giant Gash.
It was just all scar.
Like there's some closeup photos of vandelays eyes,
like you see the amount of scar tissue.
He had his crystal ball wars man.
When when I found out Gilbert Gilbert Melendez,
Ted's pause for steroids,
I almost fell out of my chair.
He's the first one where I was like me.
It was John Fitch.
Nah,
John fits of the cow,
whatever.
John Fitch he was used to talk about.
I know,
I know.
That's fucking insane.
That that leads me to the question of if they have such stringent testing for
steroids,
I feel like you're not going to see guys fighting into their thirties they're
not going to be able to compete.
And I think Gilbert Melendez,
who you know is an all time where he's one of my favorites,
just period.
I love that guy.
And I think that,
you know,
Gilbert Melendez and people like that who are now in their thirties training on
that level.
I think what you're going to see is,
you know,
it's not possible that you could make the argument that it's not possible to
find on a high level and you got to react at 30 in your thirties without some
help.
Okay.
James is just know that it's,
it's evolution came.
Okay,
but so your career is going to last.
Let's say half as long.
That's a hard pill to swallow for dudes.
Get to get their whole life looking at me.
I know,
I get it.
I know.
I'm just saying that you know,
you can't compete anymore,
you know,
and you've got to do steroids and it might be tiny,
but like
maybe this isn't the life for you.
Well he's an interesting case because he's got a legitimate medical issue.
Tumor in his pituitary gland eat that shit.
He's a different case.
But the,
he was a totally different animal when he fought Mark Hunt.
He could take monster bombs to the head.
I mean Mark Hunt hits as hard as fuck and he's one of the best strikers ever in
the heavyweight division and Mark Hunt hit him with bombs and him in big foot
went five fucking rounds of death is so much so that I have a,
a roots of fight jacket.
The Dana White had made a Mark Hunt bigfoot Silva too.
And it was,
he was so hyped up about the rematch that he had Jessie from roots of fight,
make a limited run of these Mark Hunt,
big foot silver,
two shirts,
and then the test came out and he got busted for having silver back.
Gorilla levels of testosterone.
I'm saying though,
but so if he's going to do that stuff,
okay,
can't compete.
Go find something else.
Go Do Jujitsu.
But he's really good.
You know he's a good fighter.
Mean you watched his knockout of Overeem.
I want to see that guy fight.
Yeah.
So do you say that they're all loud to have a certain level of testosterone you
have to do.
I think with this new testing that they're doing,
we're going to see more guys get busted.
We're going to see a watered down version of the UFC,
which we don't need right now.
Right.
It's already kind of watered down with how many shows were putting on.
I keep saying we like,
I'm fucking working on the bus,
but how many shows you Yossi puts on?
It's becoming a little too much.
Well now you take away all that,
you do all this testing,
you can get guys not doing shit and you can get some bullshit.
That's what pet narrows.
And although we're saying,
you know,
they were saying look like you want a task,
okay,
you could task,
but you're gonna have less exciting fights.
100% yeah,
it's true.
And that's,
but that's a real question.
I mean,
I dunno,
I feel like,
I feel like if I were a bay,
like if I had a favorite baseball player and I mean
I'm not trying,
it's so complicated in a way.
Like I had a favorite baseball player and his bat speed start slowing down in 31
32 and with testosterone he could play for another six years.
I don't want to see him today for 62 yeah.
Well how about I guess I that clients,
yeah,
man.
Roger Clemens is in his 30 or it is 49 yeah.
He got up in age and he was actually getting better.
Yes.
Throwing.
Fantastic.
The problem with that now,
if Michael Jordan could've played 10 more years doing steroids,
let them do it.
But there's a difference between that and fighting,
right?
I agree 100% and Rhonda,
Rhonda because fighting hurts the other guy like,
yes.
Well Rhonda Rousey did an interview once and she said it best.
She's like this person,
if they're on steroids,
they can land shots.
They weren't,
wouldn't be able to land.
They wouldn't have the energy to land.
If they weren't on it,
they would be able to get things off a lot.
Doping and hurts.
You can turn the tide.
They could wind up winning the,
they can do things they couldn't do if they were charitable and non sports is
different because you're talking about health concerns.
Yeah,
well you're talking about doing damage to somebody and that damage could
essentially be permanent like hmm.
No one knows better than you that the amount of training that you have to do in
order to get in tip top shape to fight is fucking ungodly.
God.
You said that that you can only really maintain that level of fitness for like
two weeks before the shit starts popping and break.
You only have the peak when before you're to fight.
You've got a month,
you got about a month at that level,
at that really high level doing three a days wrestling practice,
fucking battle ropes and fucking dead lifts and all that crazy shit and you're
going to war you ready to go to what you're,
you're got your,
because
you got that fucking engine light light and you can only do it for so long and
the amount of effort that you put in,
there's a direct correlation which we,
the effort that you put in and what you can do when you actually get into the
octagon on fight day.
If you are a guy like,
like a dos Joe's versus a June 1st sentence up Anthony pedestal,
perfect example.
Dolson Joe's trained like a fucking wild Damon and because that he had this
insane cardio,
he was working out with the Marinovich.
This guy nick curse on you.
Isn't that podcast right?
Curse out a fucking genius man.
And it would talking about the strength and conditioning work those guys did.
I mean he's breaking them,
just breaking them.
Now they're like Marinovich had Bj Penn in the best fucking shape his life.
But when beach I talked about,
he's like,
I couldn't hold my daughter in my arms when I got back home.
I'll get home from training.
I couldn't hold my daughter.
Like he would try to hold his daughter's life,
but when it came time to fight time and Diego Sanchez was in front of them,
we got to see all time.
Great.
Bj Penn,
when Bj looked across the fucking cage,
he has those crazy eyes you like best.
Yeah,
I think the person who has it,
they got fucking Bj Penn jacket.
Motherfucker down deals.
That's right.
And when did at j pen Prodigy Bitch,
I'm not mad at that.
And it all had to fight style.
No,
I mean that the person who has it down to who was kind of the first person that
talked about doing these short camps was a Ben Henderson.
We'd had,
we did an event together and I,
I was,
I forget who I was fighting,
but as a guy about to go into camp man,
he's like,
when's your fight?
And I was like,
like three months.
He's like camp the like going to camp for right now.
I was like,
when do you do your camps?
Like five weeks,
man,
I trained so much when I go into camp,
you know everything's red lining,
so I just five week camps,
but he's never out of shape.
He's never asked shape.
He's a lighter guy and he's always in the gym,
but he's saying when five weeks out he's sparring doing three days.
He can only do that for that long and he's not getting hurt.
You see Ben,
he's never,
never seen that.
I'm tired either.
He's an animal.
He,
I liked the fact that he's going up to one 70 and now that they're taking away
the ivs,
you're going to see a lot of that.
You're going to see a lot of that.
Yeah.
A lot of guys are going to be forced to it,
but also you're going to see a lot less endurance because I guarantee you guys
were blood doping guarantee you.
I know for a fact guys were blood coursing.
I know for a 20 fighting for 25 minutes.
Anybody's ever wrestled for six minutes or nine minutes,
God forbid when it goes into overtime or whatever.
That's such a long time.
It's such an easy on this.
When you literally want to die in six minutes is a crazy shit in the world.
25 minutes.
When I watch these guys kicking,
punching in wrestling for 25 minutes,
it's kind of unnatural.
I don't know how you get an that kind of shape.
I mean,
I do.
There's a lot of guys who do it now.
Well,
no,
no.
Don't,
don't get it twisted.
A lot of guys get in that shape without all that shit.
I'm never used shit in my life raising crazy shit,
so don't get it twisted.
They don't even sniff protein powder.
You know what I'm saying is when you take supplements,
yeah,
but there's a lot of guys that don't take anything and they're fine and they're
fine.
They're freaks.
There's a fine,
certainly genetic advantages have,
some people absolutely have genetic advantages and you know you can't get around
that.
There's just no matter who also can't get around guys using steroids,
looking for an advantage because there's so much money involved in the sport.
It's an individual sport.
Steroids.
I don't give a fuck if he tests the guy every single day.
Steroids will find its way to the game.
It's part of history.
I was watching Chris Kamozi versus Jack Era.
Uh,
the second fight and a exactly like the first one.
What's that?
Exactly.
And I was watching this and I was thinking to myself,
okay,
this is the,
first of all,
Chris Kamasi has got balls.
He's a tough fucking dude.
Okay.
If game is the comm games,
they come,
takes his fight short notice against the guy who already beat him,
already strangled them the first time they fought,
right?
So here he is again with this fucking monster in front of him,
He got an arm triangle,
like a white belt,
and the first fight he's got Jack Array could do that to black belts.
You need to do it to anyone that you see.
I mean,
did,
he would just manhandle you.
He just runs right through you,
right?
He's,
his Jujitsu is so tight and you so fucking physically strong.
He learned his Dj.
See where he'd come out and it's Brazil,
but what,
what school was there a p?
That's a good question.
Good question.
The time world champion.
Anyways.
Anyways,
point is,
I was watching those two together and I was watching them move around.
Jacqui's closing the distance on him and I'm like,
these are two different species.
This Jocko remains physically super athlete.
He's fucking shredded.
He's got giant pipe.
Don's for arms.
His biceps go down to his forearm.
Like when I met John Gray,
the first time I met John Gray was before he even was doing,
um,
he was doing a MMA,
he was only doing Jujitsu.
I met him in 2003 in Brazil.
His bicep goes down to here.
Wow.
It goes down like it's longer than it's supposed to be.
He had leverage.
Makes you insanely strong.
He's just got so much Jujitsu.
She's drawn to choke and he's a great athlete.
He's just a natural.
Any works that Hossein,
he's an animal,
but it's like Yoel Romero.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's an animal.
Joma Merrill is actually a better exam.
So what do you do?
So,
so if they're nuts Kamozi I'm saying is you give Chris Commodity all the
steroids in the world.
He's not gonna beat Yoel Romero.
He's not going to be that guy.
He's never going to be that guy.
He's a different guy.
I mean commodes he's tough as shit.
He'll beat the fuck out.
A lot of dudes at 185 he's world class.
But that Yoel Romero Guy,
when you watch that guy chase after Machida,
so he's fucking 40 [inaudible] curve,
his learning curve.
A silver.
What do you do?
It's a good question.
That's a good question is you can see why I get to like fuck it.
Well,
I mean,
um,
I don't know.
I don't know what you can,
it's the same thing that people who are not that athletic just don't play in the
NFL.
Now I did becomes this sport is if the money's going to be there,
this sport is going to attract more Yoel Romero is and,
and Jakarta.
It's just because you know that Yoel Romero or you're not,
uh,
terrail Owens from the NFL.
Right.
And fighting might be different because there's so much skill and technique.
Five things different because less than 1% are Ronda Rousey's there.
Jon Jones or Cain Velasquez also.
There's also some people like genetically have power.
Yes,
and you won't get that.
You do not going to get it right.
Just can't just,
you can't get,
you don't have,
the scaffold is like he's exactly,
exactly like these Mike Tyson characters.
Like did you just,
you can't.
You can teach Mike Tyson perfect technique.
You can show Mike Tyson how to throw punches perfectly and how to be you.
What you're never going to do is develop that kind of power.
It's called us.
You have that body,
you will.
There's nothing can do.
Like Floyd Mayweather is,
in my opinion,
the best boxer ever.
If you want to talk about boxer,
he gets hit the least.
He's beaten everybody,
everybody in front of them,
everyone.
It's arguable that his error is not as talented as the era of sugar ray Leonard
or all those other guys,
but when it comes to like the ability to hit and not get hit and my opinion,
he's the best.
He's not my favorite.
My favorite is Roy Jones,
Jr likers.
Roy Jones Jr was killed.
He was a motherfucker and he would,
I mean,
he just had his own style.
There was just like so much about Roy Jones who was just in his prime during
those few years.
We use red line when he was at the top,
virtually untouchable.
Untouchable.
The only God can do thou.
Yeah.
That's the devil screen shots.
Nat and clown and dude's clowning dudes and put his hands behind his back.
Guys,
I wouldn't want to make it a show of,
I mean,
he knocked out virtual hill with a body shot frame with a right hand,
not even on the liver.
Right.
Throw it on the right,
on the left side of his body.
Wow.
Go to sleep.
Just [inaudible].
He's so God damn hard.
I think the thing and fighting,
I don't mean to interrupt,
but I'm going to get to the power thing.
But Floyd Mayweather,
we'll never be able to punch like Tommy Hearns.
He'll never be able to punch like Julian Jackson.
He'll never be able to punch like John the beast.
Will Gabi or Marvin Hagler.
They don't have his footwork though.
That's true.
Words elusiveness absolutely.
He's a better boxer.
But that power thing,
you either have that thing or you do not have that thing correct and you can't,
can't teach it to beat.
Yeah.
You know the,
the thing,
the difference in fighting these other sports,
let's say on the see this 53 guys and NFL roster,
let's Say I'm the the 50th Beth best player on the San Francisco 40 niners.
I'm making a good living.
I'm really not suffering that much damage.
Let's Say I'm the 50th ranked fighter in the UFC.
It's not a pretty life man.
It's not great.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
because I'm still doing exactly what the number one guy is doing as far as
getting hit competitions,
fighting camps,
everything,
but I'm not getting the same payment.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
And you're getting hurt or gets hurt.
Him.
You getting bad at all the time.
You think about what you're making a year,
you make him like 30 grand a year.
Josie Aldo,
they not Josie Aldo.
All the press he did for the UFC.
Right.
You don't get paid for that press.
Not only that,
just can't think.
Got His camp and then he has to go through all that and then he gets hurt.
What?
12 days,
14 days before the fight?
15 days.
So all that work,
you don't get it.
You don't get paid for any of that.
What's your,
uh,
are you excited about this?
Chadman is a kind of a very excited,
very excited about as excited as,
although if not more really.
Yup.
Do you think that it's obviously a very,
you know,
they have this golden boy kind of McGregor and the,
it feels like Chad Mendez is a,
this is a big challenge because I think Chatham message should be the saver and
they show me the favor.
100%.
It should be placed.
Amaze that somehow.
Some way they didn't choose someone like Nate Diaz.
Why did they choose Chad Mendez over this?
Just,
first of all,
Nate Diaz is in a different weight class.
He's never made one 45 minutes.
Second of all,
Chad Mendez knocked Ricardo lamas dead dead with one punch.
I just got smashes.
Dude's goes after God.
It's a bad,
it's a bad,
and I got agree with Brian on this.
I think it's a bad business idea for the UFC to put Chadman is in there.
I think if there's two horrible matchups for Connor,
Chad Mendez,
Frankie Edgar,
let's do whatever we can to get Connor to fight Aldo in October.
Um,
so see,
I disagree.
I think Chad Mendez easily could be as big a star as Conor McGregor.
He wouldn't talk like Conor Mcgregor did,
but needed to.
George Saint Pierre,
George St Pierre was the biggest paper,
if you star of all time because he was a gentleman and he was a fuck.
He was George,
George,
George and Chapman does.
It is going to be twice by Jose Aldo that that's,
that's the last fight was razor close.
And there's an argument that can be made that if they fought in America,
he would have won that decision.
There's also an argument to be made that if,
if Josie,
although it didn't land that late punch after the first round that knocked
Mendez down to defend Mendez,
very hurt.
It could have been a very different fight.
Chad Mendez,
who knows how badly he got hurt by that late.
He's lost to him twice.
True,
but then he beats Lyft.
Let's say worst case scenario for the UFC.
If I'm UFC marketing team,
it's like,
God,
Connor cannot get exposed.
Let's not.
If he goes in and gets the out in the first round,
don't think later.
You going to do,
I think like that I do.
Because who's your biggest star right now?
Rhonda.
Connor.
Yes.
It goes in there.
He's talked a lot trash that we lost hundreds.
Actually,
probably a bigger star than Ryan,
which is crazy.
He would be by far the biggest star if he wins this fight.
Let me tell you something.
If Chad Mendez goes out there and starches him,
still not as Josh Connor a man.
I don't know about all that.
I'll tell you the degree,
but let me tell you this,
this,
this.
Here's some real facts.
The F the,
the numbers of tickets that are sold for this fight.
Okay,
this is going to break box office records in Vegas.
Dana White told me that the tickets had plateaued.
Nobody was buying more tickets when all doe pulled out.
And then Connor was forced to fight Chad Mendez tickets.
Sales Spike.
Really?
They went crazy.
I wonder how many were available though.
There wasn't much available,
but people were buying them scout.
But um,
Chad's family and friends bought tickets.
Dude,
I'm telling you there's a real spike.
I don't know what the numbers are,
but I'm telling you,
it's enough for Dana to talk to you.
You have Chad Mendez favorite in this fight.
This is the thing,
Conor McGregor could knock out any man in the world and 140 because of his
power,
he's got some serious fucking hands,
serious fucking hands.
He throws his kicks almost disdainfully,
almost like Nick Diaz style.
And what he's doing with his kicks in a lot of ways is creating patterns to come
in and blast you with punches.
He throws all these kicks,
like if you watch him fight Seaver,
he's throwing kicks with like minimal effort.
Like he's throwing them,
he smacking you with these kicks,
but when he lands those punches coming,
these punches have some serious poppy's beautiful.
What's up?
It is Seaver that he's doing that on.
True.
But it's also Dustin point.
He's throwing the same kicks.
He threw a front leg hook kick.
That was his first kick against Dustin Poirier.
Yeah.
He's a wild man and,
but the point is super confident.
Really believes is bullshit.
All this stuff that he's saying,
we're not here to take pause.
We had to take over.
I love it.
Braveheart,
I love the mother fuckers smell good.
Has he been,
has he been wanting them to win?
I think for the UFC he would be,
if he wins this next fight,
he's the biggest star we've ever had.
He has,
he doesn't think he's bigger than rock.
If he wins this fight,
because of my position,
because of what I do,
and I had a conversation with this guy last night.
Who are you picking?
Who you're picking?
I don't pick anybody does.
I'm going to tell you that you would asking you to let me know.
Say you pick,
there's two.
There's two times maybe ever three times ever where I was hoping somebody one,
that's the three times that you fought fights that I call.
It's true.
I don't like admitting that,
but like the midstream oil and fight,
I was like,
shh.
You know the Arlovski fight.
I'm like,
ah.
I thought you got it.
And then you know,
I think it's really hard.
It's real hard when your friends fight.
Yeah.
Real,
real,
real hard.
I'm friendly and I'm friends with a lot of those.
Not as cold slam with you,
but I'm friends with a lot of guys that fight.
I put that shit aside.
I put that shit aside and have to go into those fights like an empty objective
person.
I tried to because I've done it before.
Why I thought one guy would win and then I think maybe like flavored my,
my commentary that I took criticism for it and that I would listen to that
criticism and I'm a go.
I think they've got some good points,
you know?
And so I,
I,
I adjusted my own approach to watching fights.
So now when I watch fights,
I watch fights with empty,
you know,
I have styles that are really like,
but then I like when people beat those styles.
I agree.
Like Anderson is my favorite style of all time.
Right.
A lot of watching Anderson Silva light guys up.
I mean,
come on man.
Why out of them the Chris Leben fight or the,
you know,
the Stephan Bonner fight?
There's only one guy in the UFC that I locked right now and I'm excited to
watch.
I gotta be honest.
And it was Connor.
That's it.
Come on man.
I don't feel no,
I'm saying for me as far as like [inaudible] that
bad ass mother fucker from Mexico,
that's a lot in the last few battle.
Calmer.
I'm like excited.
I'm like,
I've never seen shit like this.
The way he moves,
the way he talks,
I'm like,
I haven't seen this.
Oh,
see,
I love watching him.
I think he's amazing.
But I am.
I'm a high on a lot of guys right now.
Right.
You know that a Amir at w was Connie.
What the fuck's his name?
I have the fuck.
Do you say,
what do you,
what do you think of,
uh,
of um,
Wonderboy Thompson?
He,
when he moves differently,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
Took tough fight.
Serious serious tracker.
Yeah.
He's tough to deal with.
Yeah,
he's a serious tracker.
Um,
I guess just as far as the common thing goes,
when I,
when they said it was going to be Chad Mendez,
I was on set a UFC tonight.
The rumor was,
is supposed to be Diaz Nick or Nate.
Nate,
Nate whites.
What?
There was that room.
Wait at that.
That was the rumor on set.
Well that's a good,
that's a good sales pitch.
Yes.
100% plus both have good hands.
It's good man shop.
I can see Conor winning that on armor.
Connors,
that he's obese.
He's a bad motherfucker.
But,
but what?
So do you think one 45 or one 45 is deep?
Do you think,
do you think that Jose Aldo,
and even though he's been a champion and just amazing,
do you think Josie also though in some ways it's actually an easier fight for
Conor and is Chapman?
No.
Hell No.
Anyone says it's nobody's.
Nobody's easy.
Josie,
Aldo is never easy,
but I'm just saying he was going to win that fight.
But Josie outfit is not a pressure wrestler.
The Way Chad men is going to execute.
Dan,
this is what's scary about all though.
First of all,
his leg kicks are as good as anybody that's ever lived.
His fucking leg kicks are lightening fast and when he lands them,
you only have a couple of those you can take because you're diminished.
Your diminished with the first kick.
I'm telling you,
man,
I've seen guys kicked live,
although has a different kind of kick.
It's so fast.
I also think Josie is fat.
I think he's faster than Conor.
Bucky.
People are surprised.
Surprise.
Oh,
he's watching.
He asked me.
He's very fast.
He's very,
very fast.
Really seen Conor is being fast.
I just see him as being in his hands.
He's very fast.
He's fast.
He asked for one 45 also has a great penetration on his punches.
He throws that left hand.
He reaches,
Ooh,
he's,
he's going through.
He bet he wanted to Bet Dana White,
3 million bucks and he knocks out chat in the second round.
What?
Yeah,
he's that confident.
See this way I was with my,
that was my next question,
but has he been,
Chad Mendez gets into the third round and he knocks Chad Mendez out in the third
round and he loses three down 3 million.
He saw your breasts can be so depressed when they're young,
right?
Like damn.
Damn man,
I didn't know.
So He's been very vocal now the same way with Chapman.
Chapman has been laughing at him though.
And Chad Mendez is a demon.
He's a motherfucker.
You ever see Chad Mendez jump out of a fucking pool further?
Well,
Chad Mendez was only five foot six,
a super,
I guess a three foot side of the pool jumps out of the pool,
lands on the fucking the edge.
And then does a back flip that's so sick to me.
That's the videos.
I watch this video
cause I seen Bj Penn do that.
Yeah,
but not flip.
Tell
like Chad.
Chad Mendez is a legit super half.
That's freaky.
But here's something that watch this shit.
I watch this shit because this is fucking ridiculous.
Watch him standing there.
Watch this watch.
He's standing there by the the three foot side jumps out of the pool.
Boom and then does a backflip right into,
he's a monster dude.
Super serious athletes.
That second fight with Josie Aldo.
If I could make one fight and put it to to the future like lock and I'm like
watch this.
This is what the UFC is.
His second fight with Jose Aldo,
the technique,
the back and forth re the five rounds.
It's one of the best fights in UFC history.
It was a great fight.
We'll fight man.
It was due to the wire.
What does that sound credible and
elite elite fighters in their prime,
a guy in Aldo who you got to think is it least top two or three pound for pound.
I think the number one guy in the world is mighty mouse.
I've said this for a while.
Just says that.
Yeah,
that's the best I can see that he's the best I can.
I see that.
I see that argument.
I just don't,
he's so good.
I think I have Josie Aldo over him.
I have mighty mouse too.
I've Josie don't because mighty mouse never slows down.
He says good and lazy.
Crown fucking that's true.
Pounds.
There's only 20 pounds heavier than for Pat.
It's cut,
cut,
cut.
I think all those fighting tougher competition he already is.
But you know what?
He makes it tougher to cause he's got a different style.
I agree.
I saw,
I saw many masks walking in the Seattle airport and it was just there I was and
he kind of,
I kind of nodded at him and nodded and kept walking and nobody was giving him,
nobody even noticed him.
And I thought to myself,
that right there is,
if he was a heavyweight,
he would be just mod.
He,
that's one of the baddest people on the planet at his wife.
Get into a club and DC was like,
Bro,
this is the world champion of the UFC.
Man.
They'd bounce was like,
okay,
go ahead.
They weren't going to let him into the club.
You don't get any land in younger love.
You know love when you're one 25 bouncers need to fucking pay attention to the
lower weight classes.
That ass get that ass whooped by.
Money,
mouth.
He'll spin around guarantee.
I guarantee fucking hard for him.
I guarantee cause he's thick.
He's out of 25 one 25 right?
He's thick.
He's not a big guy,
but he's a fucking,
he's the best.
He's an elite,
elite fighter.
The way he moves in my opinion is like every,
if I wanted a young fighter,
I said,
you want to watch somebody?
You want to learn what they do.
Watch this guy.
He got to get some body type.
You know what I'm saying?
With his style,
maybe like my fat ass when I was young,
you show me mighty mouse.
I'm like,
yeah,
no,
I just can't do it.
Well,
you're carrying around boxing boxing's that way and you can't fight the way
Floyd Mayweather or are right.
John is doing junior fights without having a lot of that ability to just st
speech.
Two words for you.
Mohammed Ali,
true.
He Muhammad Ali,
when he's losing his mind,
he had that kind of body,
but when he was in his time,
he was 220 pounds.
His physical,
his physicality,
he's such an athlete.
His,
he had all,
he was the way he would hit.
When you watch him as Cassius clay,
he moved like a little man.
He was
so fast and smooth and that that's really hard for it.
That's a very rare example of a huge guy who moved like a small guy.
You don't have to be physically.
I was wearing a brutal fight.
I said Cassius Clay's shirt.
I got one of those.
Yeah.
Love it.
Right.
It's the white ones is like my wardrobe was me to fight.
Me Too.
Sometimes I feel like an asshole.
This is wearing my white shirts all the time because I'm in line at a Starbucks.
This old white dude comes up to me.
He goes,
hey man,
that's shirts.
Offensive went what?
He was at shirts offensive I to,
I forgot what I was wearing.
I looked down,
I'm like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
And he goes,
that that,
that was a slave name.
I was like,
okay,
cool man.
Have a good day.
He's like that shirts.
I wouldn't wear that man.
I was like,
Bro,
beat it.
Nerd.
I didn't make the fucking shirt.
I'm some Mohamad Ali fan.
It's old school.
It's historical represents,
it's got fifth street gym in Miami on the patch as well.
He changed his name when he converted to Islam.
Well not only that,
he is getting proceeds from that shirt like yeah,
authorize the sale.
That shirt was that.
Sure,
of course is who he was when he fought in the Olympics.
How the shirts in your coffee.
How about pitching that dark roast?
He won a gold medal,
which he threw into the St Louis River.
I believe.
God Damn White people.
White people,
man.
Fucking white people.
Fucking like.
I've been working on this pit about how I secretly roof black people.
Like if I see a black homeless guy versus a white homeless guy,
I'm always like,
you know what man,
you probably accused of a crime he didn't commit.
Hey go and I see a white guy.
I'm like,
wash your face and wear some glasses.
Well let's keep going.
I want to work on that.
But anyways,
anyways,
cough your guys.
Hey,
that's not that big.
You asshole.
Hey,
speaking of shitty thing now on speaking of shitty things,
how about Travis Browne?
Oh boy.
Hold.
Yeah,
hold awkward.
UFC sets that you'll see at fight week said,
hey listen,
we can't have you signing and hidden bitches,
so we're going to have you sit this one out.
Okay,
so what is going on with him?
His wife,
his former fiance or wife or fiance,
right?
Instagram.
Just bully,
beat downs.
Black Guy,
horrible bruises.
Said her leg.
Everything said I'm sick of this.
I don't want,
I can't believe I stuck through it through this long.
Uh,
you know,
physical abuse,
domestic abuse is nothing to,
you know,
not a laughing matter,
whatever.
Post an Instagram picture and it's horrible.
If you guys have seen,
it's horrible.
It's interesting.
This is not on the underground.
I could sign on the front page where all the news is to try and keep the UFC
fricking be yanked him from the this fight week.
Hey Dave.
Oh yeah.
How about Brandy Palmer?
Brittany Palmer is fucking husband gets to go.
He gets $10 bought,
tempted murder,
attempted murder.
He tried to choke her,
first of all,
his Jujitsu so weak because if I'm going to,
I'm really attempting to choke her.
She said mean.
That's what I said.
I'll tell you what real attempted murder.
How is she alive?
The choke is she can Ken shamrock.
What's going on here?
I'll tell you what though,
with just with Travis Brown,
when saw that,
when I
saw this girl all beat up was like,
I,
I feel you man.
He whipped my ass.
I was like,
girl,
go for a take down.
Go,
go,
go.
For Jujitsu.
I mean how?
How he slapped the shit out of me too.
I feel he slapped up this out of me so I feel like reaching out to and be like,
you want to talk about it?
He'd beat the shit out of me.
At least is front of millions of people that you are alone.
I was in my underwear.
We beat the fuck out of me.
I don't fight anymore.
And you want to talk about it?
Do you,
do you think?
I mean when you see a girl like Brittany who's,
she's a nice kid,
man.
I mean I don't understand it.
I just don't understand smoking.
She smoked apparently he forced her and again,
a bunch of plastic surgeries to,
that's what she's also saying and it was like the reason why she had all their
work done.
The rich kid who was handed money and moved to La,
you know,
they kids in hand doesn't,
it doesn't work out.
That's what I've heard.
I don't know where he earned his plane.
I always got along with the guy.
He's always cool to me.
I enjoy talking to him when he was with her.
I mean I really,
I mean I hate saying it now because I know I allegedly know what he did so and I
hate him at,
you know,
fundamentally is one thing I will play with men like her man.
She's too,
I really like every time I talked to she's Sassy.
She's always fun.
When was joking?
She's one of the rear girls in the octagon,
which you know,
she has a talent and it's a painting.
If you've seen their dope man,
she's a good about reaching out and having her paint some shit.
A big brown putting up my house.
Oh,
she'd be happy to do.
Yeah,
she's super legit.
She has been.
So it's been like a right like a down to earth.
She's fine.
I like hanging out with her.
She's coming with some of my shows.
I love looking at Instagram late at night.
She's married.
Not Anymore.
Slip official.
Lead divorced too.
He,
he's out on $1 million bail.
1 million.
It's a weird night shit.
But,
but hear me out.
No Shit.
You hear me out on this?
Hear me out of here we go.
Go ahead.
Hit me up man.
Cause you guys,
it wasn't dented.
No,
but I'm giving them Jujitsu lessons at force or heard of this up but,
but since we don't really know the details,
when I hear,
when I hear that it was attempted murder the problem and he had choked her like
there is the question of she got out like she got away.
What?
What are the circumstances?
Like for me,
I'm always guarded about this.
I want to hear more about the case where I can then I don't know what I do.
I go,
Oh you put your hands on her.
Done.
Yeah,
it's done.
What do you mean he wants to fucking tears.
Here's
what happened.
Listen,
here's the,
you're fucking man.
Okay,
here's the only time it's okay to hit a woman,
which he's trying to kill you.
She's got a knife and she's trying to kill you.
You're saving your life and you hit her across what was happening.
We don't get to hurt that.
You would have heard that it would come out.
He would've said that he hasn't said anything like that.
There's no evidence and won't be.
That's because his lawyers are telling him not to.
Hillary dollar bond.
Britney Palmer's not trying to stab anybody.
I might be wrong.
You're right.
I don't know.
I'm just saying we're talking.
No,
no.
Fuck that.
Fuck you might.
I don't know you right.
I don't know,
but does not match.
That's the only possibility is that she's coming at him with a knife or a gun.
She's trying to kill like Chris Brown and Rihanna.
They're like,
yeah,
we'll Rihanna did some shit.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't care this that.
She did do that,
but girl,
I love punched me in the face.
I'm going to be very upset.
I'm not punching it back right now.
My whole error.
Let me take some heat for this.
I'm just kidding.
No,
I would never touch her solar plexus.
I grab her ass.
I would never hit her.
I wouldn't.
I would put her in the tightest Anaconda Josie ever seen?
No,
never.
I've never choked anybody,
but I did take my wife's back once and I put the body triangle on it just to let
her know what's up.
Obviously naked.
It's fun.
I had,
I had a girl
ever,
I had a girlfriend who would get drunk and get jealous and hit me.
She tried to take my hat off with a boot.
Did you marry her?
Nope.
Get clothes.
I don't to talk about it,
but my buddy,
we were at a party and it was all great and she was kind of person who would get
drunk and you wouldn't know it.
And,
and my buddy was there and he said,
I saw,
he said he saw the whole thing and this is where I'm just,
let me hear me out.
Cause I,
she,
she thought I was looking at a friend who was there and my party a girl and she
just attacked me physically.
And I countered by getting her an under hooks or something.
And I kind of hip tossed her away from me.
And we both crash through a window,
not a window,
but a adjoining doors,
you know,
those French doors.
And my buddy's side,
the whole fucking thing.
Glass.
Yes.
So my glass everywhere,
glass everywhere and the door broke.
That's assault brother.
Well,
hold on.
My buddy saw the whole thing from its inception.
He saw her attack me.
Somebody else saw only me hip tossing her through the,
well,
kind of not really hip hop with getting her away from me and she,
he's taught me to hit does her through the glass.
If that person that saw that,
it looked like I was thrown us through fucking doors.
I wasn't,
here's the raw buddy came to my defense and said,
just so you know,
I saw the whole fucking thing.
I saw her jump on you and attack you and you were trying to get her away and
calm her down.
And I,
and then I brought her,
I put her,
I brought her because there was a party into my garage,
held it down and said calm down.
And I was holding her physically down physically so she couldn't move and she
was screaming dapping you can sit a lot of things and you're saying if I'm a cop
and like,
hey,
that's kidnapped.
That's what I mean.
I could get arrested for assault when what I was doing was doing what I was
trying to protect myself by holding her down.
I was trying not to quit embarrassing situation
and I was trying to like sort of extinguished the problem.
Here's one for you.
What do you do?
What do you do that?
See what's that?
What do you do if you're the UFC?
They actually suspend them for just for UFC fight week.
Makes Sense.
We're not talking about Brittany anymore.
We're talking about,
you're talking about Charles Brown.
I'm just talking about also sometimes as we all know,
you can get in a situation where it's like,
just that example,
I could have been if somebody had seen a segment of that and I for sure.
Let's get it fun.
Okay,
well let's talk about reality.
Okay.
If he did beat her,
okay.
If he did and he did more than once.
Yeah.
You got to cut them of course.
Right?
You got to cut it.
Yes,
and that's what they did with rumble Johnson and then they found out were
rumble.
Johnson was a lot of bullshit.
It was his baby mama and it was a lot of nonsense and it wasn't real.
He didn't have these pictures.
There's exactly,
but there's also women that we'll pretend now I have a friend and he was
breaking up with his girlfriend and she said,
and he recorded it and she started saying things like,
you know,
I'm going to tell the police you,
you hit me,
I'm gonna throw myself down a flight of stairs.
All this kind of crazy shit.
I had it done to me.
It happens.
Yes,
it does happen.
The windows and said,
stop hitting me.
Starts screaming.
It's not like,
I think that's the exception.
I gotta be honest.
I don't know about that.
And you don't know.
It may be the exception,
but less elite girl hit her.
How about you back off?
Know there are people that are deceptive.
Dissolve.
There are people mean God girl.
Yes,
it's,
it's possible.
It's possible.
It might not.
Whether it's the exception and not,
it's not the point.
Like is it possible?
Yes.
Does it happen?
So at that time I friend who was accused of rape,
but he kept all the text messages and show the prosecutor,
well,
how am I gonna fucking guy in Virginia?
The guy with the girls walking around with a mattress on her back.
He's got text messages from her asking him to come over and fuck around that.
But yeah,
it's tough.
Yeah.
I mean that's why we have courts and that's why we have due process and that's
why in this country you're,
you're innocent until proven guilty.
It's called Habeas Corpus.
I'll tell you who I think,
but we're not,
you're,
you're guilty mail to the public a pants.
What I mean and that Travis is guilty.
You look at it in scam.
The comments are tough.
Yeah,
look,
that's it.
That might be it.
Public jumps on it right away.
If he really did do that,
he is guilty.
Right?
We all agree.
Yes.
Okay.
If he really did beat her up,
we all agree it's got be cost.
Right.
You think UFC cuts him and then he goes to host tore and just dominate.
Listen,
I think he goes to jail.
Yeah.
I mean if you really did beat her up,
he goes to jail.
Right half too.
It's just salt.
So salt brothers,
especially with a really PR,
she's beautiful.
She is smart.
She has legit bruises.
I mean he is there.
Harvey is huge.
He's a g so big giant man.
When he came and knocked down,
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
I can imagine her.
He jumped down the whole bro.
Yeah,
I mean the same way.
We obviously don't know what the fuck happened.
We don't know.
We have no idea.
I mean we could,
it could be another,
I'll throw myself down the flight of stairs.
I always take the girl's side on this.
Well,
it's the smart thing to take.
I mean,
she's the victim.
If it is,
I mean,
the worst thing you could do is question someone who's been victimized and we
may,
I don't know what really happened is fucked up,
right?
Yeah.
And for the most
part,
I think that when,
if my,
I have to believe,
and I,
it's just,
I don't know this person.
I don't know Travis.
I don't know the situation,
but I do feel like,
you know,
when you post pictures like that to Instagram,
I feel like this is definitely not the first time he's been hitting her and
she's finally had enough and decided,
yeah,
this is the only way I can purchase that.
She was embarrassed that she waited so long ago,
man.
And with a girl like that,
I mean this is the only time in human history with someone who's been able to do
something like that.
I take a photo,
put that photo on your Instagram and instant power.
Instagram.
There are a lot of countries right now in this code,
in this world where you as a wife,
if you're getting the shit beat out of you,
there are no laws that protect you.
Travis needs to move there.
Yeah.
It's a good spot for him.
If that's,
if that's his thing,
take her house there.
Yeah.
I don't,
you know,
tough.
It makes me,
when I,
when I hear like this Aaron Guy and Brittany,
I'd like the guy,
I mean,
I,
you know,
I talked to him,
I enjoyed talking to him.
He said,
was he perfect person?
No,
but obviously I wasn't in a relationship with them and I w I don't know what the
fuck happened,
which we don't know.
We don't know and I need to hear is okay.
You beat her.
You choked her.
Cool.
Not My friend.
Don't talk to me when we see each other.
That's really what happened.
It's Brittany call me and it's very sad.
Try Brittany.
I am available seven Tuesdays.
Yeah.
Ulterior motive.
You somehow if you need to play stay.
I live in Marina village.
No,
but it's not like that man.
It's fucked up.
People get to that place.
It's fucked.
The people that used to be in love,
they were lucky enough to get married and they had a big crazy wedding.
They held this hand.
We know one thing.
It's a fine line between love and hate,
man.
If there's one thing,
and they always say like the most dangerous place for a woman sometimes or even
a man is the bedroom.
Shit flares.
Fucking tempers.
Cops fucking hate going to domestic violence to someone always has to be
arrested if it domestic violence is called.
They didn't have to rest someone every time.
Smart.
My buddy off and also he said the worst case if it's two gay guys,
because gay guys think about gay dudes fight like dudes.
They know about this.
A scrap scrap or that Dick.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
I don't know if this is true.
I think about it bro.
That's true.
And I don't know if this is true,
but I heard from a cop who did a lot of a detective.
They said,
well,
well you get a lot of face stabbings in the gay community.
And I was like,
what do you mean?
He goes,
when lovers fight,
man,
you can usually tell if somebody knew the other person and hat was physical with
them,
like in love with them and physically,
you know,
sexually physical.
If their faces are,
they have 15 fucking stab with great white sharks.
Very.
That's very typical of somebody who hates like,
I loved you and now I fucking hate you.
I'm a stab your fucking ruin that face.
I'll try and ruin that.
I was gay.
Oh Gosh.
I got to go back to the Dick guys like a little scar.
No,
I get that booty hole
right.
Hey man,
you gotta stab the booty.
Oh,
come on.
Stop someone in the booty hole.
You could get the toxic in the blood.
Then we heard evil son and you know you might have to wear a colostomy bag
or something while anywhere.
Anywhere Sucks at Dick.
Could it be?
I'd probably get shot.
If you had to be standing somewhere,
where would it be?
One place you have to choose.
Go and stab me in this juicy quad.
So know you could die.
Fuck.
Big fucking arteries.
Femoral artery.
Now I'll take my chances.
If you think about it,
the quad for our forum.
Go Form Stab my forms of your hand.
Might get fucking separate nerve go Kimbo slice.
Kimbo slice told me if you ever get in a knife fight you,
you let them cut outside.
So Kimbo Kimbo had all these fucking cuts all over.
All right,
fuck it.
Let's talk about this for a minute.
How crazy is it that we talk about fights?
Like,
you know,
we're just a bunch of dudes sitting around and talking.
Then it becomes new stories.
I know the MMA media is so bizarre.
Like we talked shit about that.
Ken shamrock Kimbo fight that became a giant fucking news story.
You had rex feelings.
He's like,
Joe Rogan shouldn't do that now I do that.
Yeah,
well,
you're a powerful dude.
My man.
You know what I,
what I've learned on pack podcasts in two is,
you know,
I joke around,
I make stuff fine,
but then boom,
it's a headline like,
shit,
I better watch what I say a little bit when you joke around.
Also there's a difference between listened to you talk in context of a full
conversation,
whereas a lot of shit talking and laughing,
taking it and printing it.
When it's two dimensional,
it's on paper.
Like,
like Fox in an article where Brian asked me on one of our podcasts,
he goes,
well,
how do you think Connor's feeling right now?
I went,
Oh,
I'm sure he's terrified.
You know,
like the anxiety of fighting,
they change your opponent 12 days.
It's completely different style.
You're fighting a wrestler.
There's some nerves there,
man.
I bet he's terrified.
He's not gonna win or he doesn't believe himself.
Just naturally,
everyone's terrified to fight,
man.
What's our brand shop things?
Connor's terrified and then its fans fucking just reach out to me like they want
to fucking Travis Browne.
Yeah,
just fun.
10 fucking Brittany Palmer,
you know,
it's like brutal man.
So,
so then when you,
it's almost like now I don't censor myself,
but you can tell people get careful.
You can see how people get very sort of a,
an antiseptic and very sort of sanitized.
What was weird was what articles are being written while the podcast was going
on,
so people were sitting in front of their computer
ready.
Joe Rody.
Soon as we were talking about the Cam Sharmarke fight,
it was in podcast order in,
in articles routed.
You get Rick,
did anybody reach out to you about that,
Ken or anybody?
I'm no,
look,
I love Ken shamrock.
I'm a huge the fan,
and that's one of the reasons why I was suspicious about him not being able to
finish that rear naked choke underneath the neck,
underneath the neck on anybody with a fresh Ken shamrock.
Yes.
But I guess,
you know,
you have a good point that he's 51 and you know,
I mean,
look,
Kim is not,
he's not a joke,
but his ground game,
so he's been the weakest part of his game.
There's a,
there's a lot of issues with that fight that a lot of people have,
but the big issue was there were fights and Ken's passed and were worked.
Jack Slack did a piece on it.
Yeah,
the history of it.
Yeah.
So you're not breaking any news.
I'm not black breaking news.
Jack Slack was one of the best writers in MMA today.
He's a fucking fantastic at breaking down fights.
He did,
I think it was called the anatomy of a fixed fight.
And he did,
he showed fights from pancreas that what?
You watched them and you go,
oh,
okay,
that's worked for knocky fi,
but would it be Joe Rogan,
huge.
Ken shamrock supportive.
They're not going to write that.
Maybe,
maybe they would,
but they just sit there and wait for something.
Shop Talk Shit about
that position that he had him in is maybe the hardest thing to get out of in
the,
on the planet when you got,
when you got us back underneath like that on top of them do just got good
Jujitsu.
No,
you know,
like there's a lot of guys,
you get their back.
Like John Fitch was notorious for like you could get his back and choke him and
he figured out a way out of it.
Remember with Eric Silva,
Silva had a deep choke on them and he's like,
whatever high level guys,
but let's,
let's get,
let's not get twisted.
Kimbo slice isn't winning any [inaudible] who competition.
So I gets a little suspect.
It's a little suspect,
you know,
but it's just,
I think that Ken is,
he,
he's in an unfavorable position.
First of all,
he's a real legend of MMA.
He's one of the guys that started it all off.
If it was for Ken shamrock and his fights like Ken shamrock was huge back in the
day.
Then right before the pancreas.
Rushmore of MMA.
Yeah,
he's in there 100% so and also he created the lion's den and help guys like Pete
Williams get them out of there.
Yeah,
there was a lot of great fighters that came out of there and that whole 20
Galendo there was a whole like group of guys that came up in that era,
you know that w that wound up being like really big fighters and a lot of it was
under his tutelage.
It's just the Games is very different now.
Fights,
fights are very different.
You're dealing with the John Jones's of the world now you're dealing with a
year.
Rodriguez is,
the game has moved.
It's a different thing.
And you know,
Ken is not financially secure.
You know,
he's not a multi multimillionaire like he should be.
Right.
You know,
if he was as a pioneer.
Yeah.
If he was a pioneer in any other sport,
if he's a partner as a NASCAR driver,
if he's a pioneer in basketball or anything that he would be set for life.
You're living in a mansion,
drinking Martinis by the pool club on NBC.
Wild World of sports,
talking about fights that are upcoming and treated with the respect that he
deserves,
but he's in this unfavorable position where he's got to fight at 51 years old.
And one thing that I'd like to,
he said he's,
I've earned the right to fight for fun,
and if that's what he's doing,
if that's what he wants to do,
I'm 100% down with degree.
Look at a guy like Mark Coleman to man.
He's not doing another pioneer.
Exactly.
He's all fucked up for a second hip surgery coming up.
And again,
massive mark homophobia.
I love him as a human being,
man.
Legends.
Oh,
eight shop could do what you're doing,
making a lot of money and go be like those guys though.
Yeah,
it's too hard,
man.
But you're a different guy because you're funny and you've got to,
you got to have a fun personality and you,
you translated perfectly into,
and you're lucky,
you know Brian Cowen,
but without those,
the Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
Without those things,
it's like,
it's hard for these dudes.
Like a guy like Brian.
Stan I think has a real future in podcasting because he's,
he's brilliant and he's very articulate.
He's very smart.
Like Brian.
Stan is a smart,
sharp mother.
Really sharp dude.
Sharpe shames me with his,
with his,
I dunno.
Jolynne just his character.
It can be president.
I know for him to eat,
I'd vote for him in a heart to him till he was like,
Hey,
a lot of fighters I know love the Reebok deal.
When I saw that I was like,
oh,
you hurt my feelings Stan.
Stan.
I thought we were bullying and,
and then I'm like,
whatever.
I get over that and I see seal chill zone and this Reebok deals.
Amazing.
Sonia said the same thing.
Oh No,
they got,
well they made good livings shot too.
They got to you.
The shirts are good looking
pause.
Just a very quiet,
you just hear a dog barking.
Well get blurred.
Melendez Gilbert,
give blurt blue.
Spell the spell.
His name alert.
They spelled a bunch of people's names wrong.
I mean,
how do you do that?
Check crazy.
They don't care.
It's not their world.
MMA is not their world,
not the world.
They didn't care the world.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
it's no big deal.
I don't want you to do,
I think it sucks for the fighters that that can't make as much money because I
think that it's a fucking,
it's a hard road.
I mean,
to try to make them as it is hard,
hard enough as it is and now just got way harder.
Yeah.
It just got way harder for a lot of guys would I hope is that there's another
revenue stream that they haven't figured out.
I hope this was a shining.
It's there for over lining.
The silver lining is don't have Reebok in the UFC.
Tell your story.
If Amaa,
and we've talked about this before on here,
if I'm a guy like,
uh,
Chad Mendez,
I'm having tee-shirts sprint and I'm saying,
this is my official shirt champions shirt.
I get 100% of the proceeds.
Right.
Instead of buying this bullshit,
Reebok shoot for $95,
which I have nothing to do with.
It's horrible.
Come on dude.
That's so expensive.
Yeah.
Go to go to Chad and whatever he has Chad mendez.com and buy this shirt.
This is what supports me.
This is shirt that I created.
Reebok,
we have no creative authority.
What I was thinking is like,
you know how fighters,
like one of my favorite things to watch up up to fights when I get really hyped
up.
So I watch all their videos.
They're putting up of training footage,
all this different Shit I get.
I'm like,
if you had like organize shit,
like if camps put together Oregon and like some guys do,
you know like Mcgregor's done psalm and,
and some guys like we'll have cameras follow them around and training and those
can get a lot of hits.
Oh these fucking things.
Get a lot of money off that.
Now think if you're wearing a shirt that you approve and you design your winning
all those vignettes,
what I'm saying going to jump on.
Say you have a training video and it's all like torque one.
You know your rise company,
my opinion,
the best fucking gloves between them and Higher Bussa Ohio boost has got higher.
Bussa has the best fucking tie pads.
Yeah,
they're fucking tie pads are so good.
My trainer Justin,
his arms are so fucked up.
I would make his arms go numb and his,
his elbows,
he would get these spikes up.
His elbows is whack because he's holding regular tie pads.
Fucked his forearms up.
But these higher Bussa ones,
dude,
full blast,
full Renaud products him,
he could take them cause they're super thick.
They're super thick and they're all this high tech foam shit and they absorb the
shot.
I mean you probably wouldn't want to hold pads for Pedro his own,
but he could,
he could take my kicks.
So have high Bussa Pay Chad Mendez to have those in this video.
Exactly.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like maybe there's a revenue stream that they haven't tapped into.
Maybe there's like something like that.
Make your own shit out of way.
Make your own shit is good too.
I like that idea.
I was on set of a major hit podcast.
You guys are the fighter and the kid,
like I told you when,
when I did Brian's,
um,
for the taping of Brian standup special,
and I came to that show and I was like,
oh,
it was just see a fighter in the kitchen about,
we were in San Francisco and I said,
any fighter and get fans sold out every show.
I went,
oh my God,
this is the boiling point.
Now it's starting to happen.
I get that.
And you can say,
well,
you have a pocket sell shirts,
but a guy like Conor McGregor,
Ronda Rousey,
you can have your own shit instead of having Reebok's.
Yes,
I agree.
It just doesn't make sense to me.
I was on set of eyes is the UFC now or you'll see a night,
and I was talking to guy,
I'm not gonna say his name.
And I go,
Bro,
why would you have your fans pay $95 for this Reebok shoe?
Do you like it?
He goes,
no.
I said,
and you retweeted it and instagrammed it.
That's weird to me.
Just have someone.
If your managers tell you this,
they trying to play ball.
They're trying to play ball.
They're trying to be a good God.
They're trying to be a company person,
so the only option they think they only have one option.
Not though because if you want to play ball,
you know what happens at the end of the ballgame.
You're left with no money.
Do your own revenue shit man.
They think that if they play ball along the way,
they'll get more bonuses,
there'll be favored,
they'll get more,
they're getting better deals.
The UFC and the UFC does take care of people they'd like and people that work
with them,
they do give out bonuses.
They do.
There's a good deal to that.
Why?
Why depend on that trend on that?
You can create your own signature shirt man and you,
you smart motherfucker businessman.
We should start teaching seminars to fighters about how to,
like you should ask some ice optimize their ability there.
But again,
when you have that,
they don't as you're funny,
you know,
if a guy's not funny,
it's going to be real hard to push a podcast unless you're real sharp guy like
Stan,
forget the podcast.
What you just said is interesting.
Like if you had cameras following you around and you and,
and they're capturing all the ins and outs of your training and be honest,
like show that,
look where you feels like shitty or you feel great and all the relationships
you're trying to deal with.
And at the same time you've got product placement,
which is just I use,
hi Bruce,
how are I use this kind of stuff.
You can make money that way.
You can make money,
but it's a lot more top tier and it's also a lot of productions extra stuff to
think about.
It used to be,
you put that fucking,
what does it fastener,
what's it called?
Dynamic.
Yet you can it that across your deck and you're making 20 grand.
You know what I mean?
It's like they had the shirts on.
Okay,
now we got to do a different route.
Now you got to get a different route.
Man,
I don't like that.
They have to do a different round and you don't like it either.
I hate it.
That's what drives me now and so like the UFC x or this is the first x y I've
ever missed.
I've been at everyone.
I love him,
man,
and the fans were like,
oh,
this is bullshit.
Because I said,
I don't work for free.
I'm not doing a fire in the kid podcast.
Live for free.
I'm not doing that.
They wanted you to do it for free.
I'm not,
I'm not doing a sign in for free.
I'm just not going to do it.
But to do a podcast for free,
you guys would still put ads in those podcasts,
not a live one.
There's no ads at a live podcast at the UC expo.
Well,
I don't understand.
When you do your ads,
do you do your ads?
You read them live on the air.
Typically.
I used to do it like that,
but then I got named Jim who?
Vernon in my life.
No,
but if you do a live podcast,
I'm not doing,
you know what I'm saying?
It's more,
it's a different scenario,
but put that up on iTunes and you put ads on that.
We don't know when it did.
It would just be for that crowd toward it.
No,
we didn't last time.
What?
Yeah.
Why would you not record it and put it out?
I don't think.
I don't think we had the capabilities.
Again,
you need a man like young Jamie,
and you're like the sound of your time,
but listen,
if there's a soundboard,
the soundboard is broadcasting out to those people.
It's got a fucking auxiliary plot.
He plugged in and you put an MP three recorder.
My right.
Yeah,
that's it.
license and then you make money off the ads from that podcast is not free.
I would do a podcast.
They asked me to do a podcast in the fight,
the fan expo.
I had done it,
but it probably wouldn't want me to.
Okay.
We've done it before.
I liked doing them.
[inaudible] is,
the point is,
is we don't have to do that.
And we offer,
listen,
you Damon athlete,
that's been the USC who's been more open.
You can,
I give you free shit for six hours a week doing podcasts,
but there's never been an athlete in the UFC more open than I have talking to
fans.
So missing the fan expo,
it's not the end of the world.
Right?
Well,
you were already getting your own message out there on a regular basis,
but you mess this is also independent.
You,
you're not a company man.
You're here,
you're rolling,
you're the coach,
you're a company man of the company's great and you're a huge supporter of view.
I've seen huge supporters,
but you're honest.
You know,
like that's fucking,
it's hard to,
that's hard to,
that's important.
It's important.
It's hard to find.
It's hard to find a guy with balls like that.
But you also can do it because you're making more money from podcasting than you
do from finding,
correct.
I mean that's just,
yeah,
she just the way of the world,
man.
So we are the world interest.
It's a this,
this sport is still growing.
You know,
there's still some stuff to be worked out.
I,
you know,
and I don't have the answers.
I don't know.
Let's do that.
I'm not,
Dana's not at fault.
I'm,
I'm sure I might run it the same fucking way.
I'm not saying would do anything different.
I don't know what I do hard chocolate.
I'll tell you right now.
I definitely wouldn't do it this way.
[inaudible] we were regards to cutting the sponsors.
I would avoid anything to cross the fighters money,
but I think they think that long term it's going to make the fighters money and
maybe they're right.
But for a guy like,
like me or a guy who,
you know,
Mitch reone or a guy like Ben Rothwell,
these guys currently on it,
it's not helping us.
Those guys should be logged on,
but it makes a benefit within like the next two or three years.
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Because of Mitre,
like a guy like Ben who's on a tear right now,
Roswell and another like two,
three years.
Any,
you know,
who knows.
Not Young.
No guy like DC is not young.
Yeah,
that's true.
And Ron does knees.
She'd fight in another five years is her knees were fucked up.
I mean shit from judo,
her knees,
her knees aren't the best.
Right.
She can't do like roadwork and stuff.
She can't run.
She doesn't want to run.
Yeah,
it needs are.
Yeah.
Well it's also like,
you know that without the human growth hormone,
without any sort of,
I mean,
when they're,
when they're testing for everything,
the way they're testing now we're gonna see a different playing field and you're
gonna see younger fighters,
UFC fighters and they get to see him retire.
See shorter careers.
Tennessee 38 year old when I was making the same money with Philip who just
retired,
really costly,
a good fighter man fighter.
When he came into the UFC,
he's like top 10 right away.
It could one of these five fucking vicious palace muscular like weird,
like Tim Kennedy kind of muscles.
Well,
he was great under Ray Longo when he left Ray Longo,
you know,
I think there was a sort of a bit of a conflict because he was one 85 Chris
Weidman was the champ,
you know,
how can you train with the champions and who knows what kind of training
sessions they had to,
I mean,
what led him to lead to leave rather what's going on with Tim Kennedy?
Tim Kennedy,
he was talking about,
he's another,
he's another guy who who's not like do what?
Yeah,
he
doesn't have to do like God.
Tim Kennedy is not anybody's bitch.
Period.
Oh,
he's not.
He should be running things.
If Tim Kenny vote went for president right now,
I'd vote for him.
I go farm.
Tim Kennedy,
Brian Stann fucking president,
Vice President Combo.
I'm in.
I'm in sign me up.
Stop reason why vote for Tim over Brian's cause Tim does that have any,
you know,
there's no investment with UFC.
He's like,
do what?
No Man,
I don't work for you guys.
I don't,
I don't have a TV show.
I'm not doing it.
Announcing,
did you see what he said when the Reebok deal came out?
Tim?
Yes.
He'd say,
oh,
she's like put out some tweet.
Um,
are you saying me to do that?
You're going to give me $2,500 to be an exclusive,
my exclusive sponsor.
Uh,
thank you very much for your generous software,
but I'll pass that Scott Coker.
What's up?
Yeah.
How,
how does that not violate your current contract with UFC?
Have you looked at,
I don't know.
I mean,
obviously it doesn't,
if they,
if they're doing it,
wow.
I mean,
they're not stupid.
They,
they have the best lawyers in the world.
There's a reason why they can do through stuff.
There's always wiggle room.
I know.
You know what?
I don't,
I don't think that it's a bad thing to get a big company involved and to
legitimize,
you know,
the passport.
If I'm reading blocked,
I'm like,
hell yeah.
Right.
If I'm rebounding,
like,
damn,
we got,
we got all these guys,
we get Tim Kennedy for $2,500.
It's the best deal in the world,
right?
We get big brown for 10 grand.
Oh,
hell yeah.
Man,
this is crazy.
When you look at what those guys were making before that though,
it's just like man,
the to make the fighters take the hit like that.
Well how many fighters though?
We're able to generate sponsorship money as far as like,
was it the top five now the guys who have great personalities like Donald
Cowboy,
who the fuck doesn't want that?
Who doesn't want to sponsor cowboy?
Yeah.
You know,
like I would buy a certain beer if I knew that Donald Serone drank after wins by
knockout,
he wins by knockout.
I'll fucking go.
I'll drink a case of Budweiser that just to represent.
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
you better come of my fucking standup.
Does a few guys like that that you'll like,
like if,
if like Cain Velasquez wins,
you might drink to [inaudible].
If that was his sponsor,
just like for cane clink glasses.
What would someone like Donald Cerrone be making now with Reebok?
Like,
so he was,
let's say it was making a hundred grand,
15 fights or 16 fights that,
I don't know.
I don't like it.
Me Neither know I don't want to get in trouble.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't like talking about it.
I just wish,
I wish guys made more money and wish it was more money for them to make.
I wish there was more opportunities for them to figure out a way to retire
safely and comfortably.
The old story with fighters and that hasn't always been the case.
Look at,
that's also the thing with boxers.
Everybody wants to compare to Floyd Mayweather.
You watch Floyd Mayweather fight.
You pay attention to how much those guys make the first fight of the night.
Pay attention to how most guys make on the undercard.
Very little.
Boxing in a way is probably worse than the UFC.
It is worse than the UFC.
Only thing is is Floyd Mayweather owns a piece of the promotion is 1% 0.01% he
is.
He's the fucking Mack daddy of the Mac Daddy's.
He's the man.
Yes,
he's beat the game.
Here's a lot of top guys that will make $1 million a fight.
You know like there's,
there's a bunch of guys that do real well.
You know,
the only thing I don't like is,
is if you do say,
man,
I don't like me.
I think the Reebok kids are terrible.
Can I help him out 100% I think they're awful.
I there should be no repercussions for saying that.
There should be no backlash for saying,
well,
if it's under not,
here's the deal.
If it's undeniable that it's good,
your opinion doesn't mean anything.
But if you say they look like shit and it resonates,
then they've got a problem with their design.
Like,
look,
you might not like this fucking Elvis in Japan shirt.
I'm digging.
That shit's dope as fuck.
Hell yeah.
You could tell me some people might like it,
but just because I don't like it.
Cool man.
You could tell me all day that they,
I,
some people are going to say it's cool.
It doesn't matter,
right.
No matter what.
Tell me all day that it sucks.
I don't care.
You could tell me all day that Bj Penn jacket is stupid.
Just say it all all day.
I don't care cause I mean anything to me.
Well,
you're definitely wrong in my mind for how I think what I like,
which is wrong.
That's your opinion,
right?
It's like you're calling me into the car.
Someone could say,
yeah,
but Porsche looks like shit.
You be like,
Oh,
good luck with that.
Are you talking about bro with the poison nine nine one big modern port.
Good luck.
Good luck with all that.
Right,
but when you say the Reebok kits sucks and you go,
you did say something interesting about Reebok,
like shoes.
They'd had a tough time marketing their shoes.
Like,
I don't know a lot of people like where are the shoes?
Crossfitters,
they're big and crossfit.
Crossfit.
They sponsor a huge cross guarantee.
Huge in Europe.
Yeah.
I guarantee most crossfitters who go to crossfit gyms don't worry box.
They wear their shoes.
You're a pussy.
Feels just like American pussy.
The same bill.
It's not like Mexican cocacola
formula.
I mean,
what could he do man?
The Reeboks.
Yeah,
man,
look,
dude is what it is.
Listen,
there's nothing we can do.
Yeah.
Look if someone gave me Reebok sneakers in cities,
the only sneakers you can wear it for the rest of your life.
It wouldn't hurt me.
Trash.
Yeah,
but it's whatever.
I'm just kidding.
Just kidding Brendon.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Yeah,
man.
I think that,
uh,
it's good that a big sponsor has gotten involved with you.
I think it's good for a bunch of big sponsors get involved and then that 10,000
becomes 100,000.
That'd be sweet,
man.
Damn,
that's the goal when we're talking.
But I think that with the Reebok thing,
it's an exclusive apparel contract because a lot like fight chicks,
they could,
they had to say that they weren't going to be at the expo and a lot of other
apparel companies say they weren't going to be at the B Cam.
Yeah,
you can't because Reebok is the exclusive apparel contract.
Uh,
we used to,
I used to make good money off the expos too.
There's a lot of those companies that you'd be a great weekend for me.
Yeah.
It's not great weekend.
I'll do six,
seven appearances.
Good money,
man.
Damn.
It's not the first one I've ever missed.
Listen,
when you make these,
when you make these big decisions,
you're not worried about guys like Brendan Schaub.
You're not worried about these other guys.
So you're worried about the best thing for the company.
And I'm not saying that to Dana White.
It might be a great decision.
I don't know that.
And they take people like Rhonda and Connor and they give them exclusive deals
where they get big money.
So Ronnie gets big money.
John Jones had big money before his car accident.
Connor Connor is big money.
Y'All year Rodriguez got slammed.
Mcdonald's pays on it.
Entity.
Yup.
Banking.
And Rory does.
Does Reebok still have to keep sponsoring Jon Jones?
No.
No,
no,
no.
He's,
they canceled that immediately.
Immediately.
He's not well,
he's suspending death.
Well,
no,
no.
He canceled it before he was suspended.
None.
No,
no.
But if he's still,
but let's say he fought next month he's wearing Reebok.
So you're still sponsoring Jon Jones?
Yes,
but he's not exclusive.
He doesn't have the exclusive deal that he had before when they were sponsoring
him.
Outside of his fights,
fighting with Reebok on your sponsor.
If Travis Browne,
let's say whatever,
he beats up his wife and he fights next month.
He's still Rocky's wearing a Reebok.
They don't let there like it or not.
You're still sponsored that very weird place for Reebok to,
because now they have to kind of get involved in whether or not this guy fights
because that can be,
that's very damaging to,
that's a big risk for them.
Where you go,
you fucked up.
They use
more pros then.
I don't know.
I mean it's a good point though.
I Dunno man,
because now they're kind of,
they can't help but get involved in whether or not this guy fights and Reebok
and where's there.
If you've been,
let's just say it's the same as the NFL before the trial comes out.
I ray rice place,
you have a Reebok or Nike Jersey on.
I'm wear Nike.
They can't control that,
but you can sponsor everyone.
You have to sponsor everyone.
You're going to sponsor some bad apples,
but most are good,
right?
I Dunno.
Yeah.
That's everything.
Thanks man.
It's true.
It is a,
it's one of those things where you've got a big company and they have their say
and then they have to protect their name.
You know?
Do you think that a compromise would be that one guy would wear like plain
shorts?
Reebok would say,
you know what,
we just can't.
Yes,
you might want to let,
when I wouldn't be a uniform,
I wouldn't be surprised that they said that.
I wouldn't be surprised if they said,
hey,
in this case,
you know,
but I wouldn't be surprised if they gave them the exact same shorts but didn't
put a logo on it.
If they had a compromise and made him wear Reebok short but didn't have the logo
on it,
you couldn't wear anything else.
They might,
but it would have to be like extreme example where there's like a debate and a
fucking closed room.
It's interesting.
And Dana White's heads turning red and fucking Reebok guys yelling too.
And then all right,
here's the deal,
here's the compromise.
You know,
it would have to be one of those teams.
Just say it'll be Reba and no k on the end to do it.
First of all,
let's break down this fucking card because this card is insane.
This is,
I think,
may don't say better than UFC 100 I'm going to pass out one of the best cards of
all time.
Listen to what we got here.
We got shut.
Shut the fuck dude.
How could you disagree?
I'm going to piss off a brand.
Men.
Boys reach as long Mcgregor.
I fucking love it.
Okay.
Robbie Lawler versus Roy MacDonald over life.
Fucking.
Now let's talk a little bit about that.
Keep gone.
No,
but hold on a second.
Here's a fight.
People sleeping on Dennis Bermudez versus Jeremy Stevens.
That's a good fucking fight,
man.
That's a very good fight.
Here's another five people were sleeping on gunner Nelson versus Brendan Dassey,
Brandon,
thatch.
That's,
thank you very much.
Not You.
Different faces in a very dry.
That's a good fucking [inaudible],
man.
That's fucking good fight.
That's a very good fight.
And Gunnar Nelson,
by the way,
Gunnar Nelson is wicked fucking ground fighter.
Really choked out.
Jeff Manson beat Jeff Monson.
Bro.
I might not choke me.
He beat him if he'd just beat him.
He didn't choke beat somebody choked him out recently,
but he's from Iceland.
They're all wearing Reebok now.
Wow.
If we could,
I mean to say this,
one of the best cards all the time,
you bring up UFC 100 it will knock your dick in the dirt.
Matt Brown versus Tim Means Motherfucker.
No one's even talking about that shit.
That's a good fucking fight
for me.
That's a great fight,
man.
That's a Chinese.
What?
FC 100 is bigger than this?
UFC 100 is bigger than this
last one.
Not to me.
Are you fucking shitting notes?
It's bigger on paper as far as like the appeal,
but as far as like stylistically Alvez,
Dan Henderson,
GSP,
Thiago,
Alves time.
Here's a question.
What are the biggest superstar app they,
these superstars.
These are two Munsters flower wise.
These are great.
That's all I give a fuck.
Talking about superstars,
Joe Rogan,
he's talking about her mother fucker.
Brennan go to youth and 102 means knock the dirt.
Back in the day.
There was Superbowl cards.
He just turned it off.
I don't like,
no.
He did a super bowl.
Why is John Howard,
who was going to fight Brandon?
Thatch Y,
Z now fighting somebody else in the prelims in the undercard accuse me,
but John Howard was supposed to fight,
fight Brandon thatch.
Hey,
100 injuries.
You can see 100 on the undercard is John Jones.
Mark Coleman,
what?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I like this card.
Look at that.
Look at the main Khan Jones versus Jayco.
Brian,
come on.
That's a slaughter.
Stilts.
Jon Jones on an undercarriage.
John Jumps before he was a champion,
a fucking monster.
He was a bad moving in the dark,
but Matt Brown versus Tim means it's a better fight to me than Jon Jones was the
Chicco.
Brian John John's versus Jayco.
Brian is an opportunity to watch John Jones choke out.
Jacob district spend.
That shit was so dope.
Tim Means Versus Matt Brown is going to be a fucking crazy war.
Look at that.
Look at that main card.
It's a good fight.
Oh,
much good car.
Henderson versus Bisping is an all time classic.
I remember with that George people knock out,
they came and show that finishing yell.
No.
Remember when came down there like edit bench itself and that shit.
He killed him.
Yeah,
they took that off.
Launched him outstand Hindou's signature logo.
Yeah,
him flying through the air.
Imagine being Bisbing and seeing that logo everywhere for it and knowing what
that man ain't Pierre when he goes,
I pulled my groin and and uh,
Craig Jackson goes,
then hit him with your groin.
I thought it was the weirdest thing to say.
I was like,
wow,
there it is not very helpful when there weren't so many cards.
Like I think we're used to a little bit of Wa water down card.
So we're like,
damn,
this shit is blockbuster son.
It's good if you go back the back in the day there was some fucking super wall
card.
Yeah.
There's some big names there.
There's definitely big names there.
Mark Houma versus Stephan Bonner to me is not as interesting as Gunnar Nelson
versus Brandon.
Thank you.
100% that's a bigger fight or flight.
Yeah.
Being here.
I Dunno.
Better,
bigger doesn't mean anything to me.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm there for all of them.
So for me aficionados,
you're fucking,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
oh I know my tastes are d.
Look,
I want to tell it to me whether Manny Pacquiao fight.
I love that.
Me Too.
I love that to be,
you know boxing.
You understand how difficult it is to do with Mayweather.
Did do a guy like fucking pack.
Yeah.
This fight is going to be chaos.
Chaos because both these guys are animals too.
Dirty bird.
What is causing the most underrated guys in the UFC right now,
Tim means is a fucking savage.
He is a very skilled fighter.
Phenomenal match,
a very,
very good match and Matt Brown is more fighters like Santa styles or styles.
Very,
very,
very similar lives.
Mirror images of each other.
Matt and Josh and gets thrown out the window.
Both guys are warriors.
Matt Brown is a fucking demon.
He's a hero.
He really is.
He is a d steal souls bro.
Straight up breaks guys.
He really never,
I never seen a guy break guys away.
Matt Brown does.
He's a totally different animal.
You know,
he doesn't always win,
but you know the,
the Hendricks fight exposed a whole in his game,
man,
that guy like Hendrix could just take them down grind to Maui to take down to
know this is like,
yeah,
let's do this.
Let's see what happens.
That's going to be a wildfire.
Buy Low and that's a perfect fight for Fox sports.
One prelims to get people to set up to watch the main event on paper view cause
you're going to be frothing at the mouth by the time this fight is over.
I just loved the dirty bird.
I think that's the greatest animal.
He's a wicked and he's got evil eyes from Atlanta as a motherfucker when I
interview them.
And one was like,
Ooh,
that sounds like darkness gets dirty bird.
There's both,
these guys are doors on the early prelims.
Anyone hey,
okay,
well those early prelims keep,
keep,
keep going.
Paul Penn dread versus what site to who is the old man?
He looks like a dentist.
The guy on the right.
The crazy shit.
It's a tough guy.
I'm about two taps on,
I don't know,
Dude.
That salt
is a very,
very crafty fighter.
Let me tell you something.
He's old.
He's like 35 every bit of seven it looks 75 years old there.
I mean,
that's impressive.
Well,
let's,
how old does he find out how old somebody put his face on a body?
I might be,
I don't mean to be disrespectful,
but that's you.
To watch him fight.
Incredible.
It's very skillful shit and cubes.
Bribe.
I try to be a dick.
I will.
Okay.
Let's take a guess.
How old do you think Neil is?
I'm saying he's 16 he just turned eight.
He's 52 just turned 59 here's what you guys are assholes.
We're just saying 35 thank you.
And my knowledge of age is impeccable.
He,
I like watching him fight.
He's a crafty veteran.
I appreciate the fuck out of that.
Got me two minutes
to get his hands on.
Brian.
I called his lap.
He would,
he would rape you.
I would love that.
I called his last fight and I enjoyed it very much.
Hey guys,
I'm just saying it's a bad picture.
Smokers.
No joke dude.
Smoke as a tough kid.
This is a good fight.
That's a very good fight.
I liked that fight.
Brad.
Pixie versus I need is a good fight.
Look at the big fights we were discussed Nelson versus,
that is a big fight to me.
Matt Brown versus Tim Means I'm looking forward to that fight as much as any
fight this year.
Really?
You know why?
Because that's fucking the style wise.
The style wise is pure chaos.
Well Wise Matt Brown,
it's very skillful means it's very skillful.
Whole percent for Roche.
Ferocious.
I love that fight and Nelson versus dash.
I fucking love that fight.
I'm she styles big clashes style since not exactly a finisher.
Well he can if he gets you on the ground,
but that she is a warrior does take any huge Kao power is undenying stand up at
some of the best than the Dennis Bermudez was on a roll until Lopez.
A llama stops when llamas stopped him and [inaudible] seven zero two get caught
up with that beautiful canteen.
Lamas.
Skeptical,
Sidestep Kia team.
We traps that arm.
Who Bermuda's is Bonnie.
Yeah.
Kick ass thighs.
But Donka dark brown to get it all brown ass on.
Jeremy Stevens.
You want to talk about a murder or a striker?
That kid can fucking bang and he's getting better all the time to train in down
there.
And I'm in San Diego.
I don't the man the cards,
ridiculous.
Robbie Lawler versus Rory Macdonald.
People were selling songs about that.
Their sleep.
I know you don't want to call things,
but Robbie Lawler is a mother fucker dude.
You know why his mother Rdo late Liza rounds to yup.
And he knows how to pace himself.
He didn't kind of,
in the Hendricks fight,
he kind of went at him guns blazing that first round.
Tried to kill him.
I heard he doesn't spar.
He does.
He doesn't,
he used not stopped for a long time,
but a big part of his resurrection,
his him training at 18 te,
te,
te.
They went to American top team.
Shit.
His,
uh,
that was a big part of his resurrection is also he started sparring again there.
Got It.
He looks like a bad mother.
She's just so calculated it.
And when they fought last night,
it was a close fight,
remember?
Yeah.
And Roy had a fucked up ankle.
No fight.
Yeah.
I think a lot of cheeses nickname again.
Now he's the Red King Sun.
He was areas that Canadian psycho.
He likes red king.
I think it's where the best,
I think he's,
I think he and Carlos Condit.
Yeah.
I'd let,
that's the fight I'd like to see,
I think was the best 70 pounder.
I would like to see that.
I think he's going to win this fight and they very fast.
I know that he was a lot younger.
Oh,
he was real young.
I was 21 I think,
you know,
uh,
Roy's the favorite in this crazy,
but he's a different fighter,
Rory.
I can see it.
Those Robbie,
Robbie,
Robbie's lately Campion of the pharmacy world is that he's a different fighter
too and he's going to come into this fight.
A different fighter.
This is a very interesting fight,
but if Rory can start picking apart technique wise,
that's when things get interesting because Rory with full movement,
Roy had a fucked up ankle in that fight.
I think Roy wins this fight.
Detroit wins this fight and close fight Robbie's site or Robbie does what he did
in the first fight and it hurts them bad.
I agree.
Then maybe even finishes them off.
Who knows?
I love that fight.
I like,
I like Roy.
That's going to be just his,
that's going to be incredible.
Maybe has McGregor man
Mendez.
I have no idea what to expect in that fight.
Mendez took this fight on short notice,
so you would,
a big factor in this fight is how much was Mendez training before he got the
call?
How much was he training?
Because your five rounds.
Here's another factor.
Are they allowed to use ivs in this fight?
I don't know.
That's for Chad Mendez fight the big cut for both guys.
Right?
They said that Conor Mcgregor,
according to Chael Sonnen,
Conor McGregor is cutting 27 pounds this week.
Oh my God.
Seven d two one seven and I believe a man,
when he said,
when I stand next to him,
fuck,
he's a big dude.
Big Dude.
See that picture of me and him next to each other.
I was like,
damn,
he's very wide and you know,
I mean that's one of the reason.
Yeah,
he's thick and you know it's all where the punching power comes from.
It's all shoulders and I love Chadman I,
I love Mendez.
He's one of the good guys.
He's the best guy.
Conor McGregor is ever fought cars.
No,
not even close.
He's a totally different,
I can't Connor beat a guy to this level.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that is the question.
I want to see him do it.
Agree.
I root for greatness.
I want to see great.
I do too,
but I root for Chad's greatness as well.
Like I said,
I love both guys.
I think if I'm the UFC brass,
we want Connor to win,
but we're not giving them any fucking layups.
This is a conversation that Dana and I had on the phone.
I said,
listen man,
you got to think about who is your biggest paper view star.
And it was a gentlemen,
George St Pierre was the biggest peer review star.
Good looking gentlemen and that's Chad Mendez.
But guess what?
George St Pierre was always foreign away.
Just he'd beat everybody and he always know Matt,
Matt Serra and knocked him on one IX after that,
but want to know he was he across to everybody no matter who is tapped him out.
Look,
he lost.
I know that that was what that was.
Two guy or so students stay with him when he became champion.
Do you understand this?
The same thing with Mendez.
Same thing with Mendez.
Mendez lost twice to the best fucking guy on the planet earth.
True.
He lost once by knockout.
He got caught with a needle.
George was a a different star because he represented Canada and u so dominant
for a very,
very long time after he lost,
says,
when's this?
I think this belt rotates.
That's what I think too.
Who knows,
man or Mendez could go on,
Goddamn Tara and become a dominant champion.
Knock out all during the rematch for the title for the undisputed title.
Anything can happen.
It's a different time because he was doing it this
way.
Morton one 45 is as deep as it gets now.
And there's the dark horse killers.
Amor Connie killer [inaudible] Rodriguez Driggins is fucking terrifying.
Terrifying.
2123 years old.
One 45.
How about fucking uh,
Max Holloway?
That mother fucker gets better every time he fights it with Cub Swanson.
Fantastic.
We heard is Kyle [inaudible] Gregory beating him,
got him on the ground in a guard pass position popped as you pop.
Does this Conor McGregor have wrestlers he trains with who are on the level of
like,
he's not training with a Mendez,
but he's trained with very good.
Yeah,
he's seen you don't get this level of Outbrain,
but as far as like a high level MMA wrestler who's also a banger like Chad
Mendez,
we tough to find.
It's only like a few guys on the planet and Candice.
So how do you prepare for that kind of pressure all the time?
You just have guys constantly trying to take,
well,
it's a different game.
See,
he's got a different,
the thing is he's fighting a totally different style now.
He was going to fight a guy who he probably didn't really have to worry too much
about taking them down when he had to worry about is being heavy on his left
leg.
If he stands Orthodox,
you've gotta be real careful because all those kicks come 30% faster than
anybody else in the division.
They come and that fucking Shin is a whip.
It just why hitting that thigh and then you feel the throbbing and you realize
like,
oh my God,
I can't take money that your rye,
a faber fight is a Goddamn wake up call to anybody you want to learn about what
happens to your fucking leg.
True Frankie Edgar,
Frank Gagra put a stop to those leg kicks.
He just dove into a double leg every time it had happened.
Frankie and literally really had motherfucker.
He just blew and then he stopped throwing that leg kick.
He stopped throwing it.
Well,
that's his boy,
right Henry?
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Mark can Mark Henry really fucking is a fantastic coach,
cause a mastermind.
They really would just dive in like he'd get kicked him Tom and just go into it
and then she like,
I don't want to find to me man.
Very interesting.
It would be interesting.
And they both had full camps.
It's interesting now with the added element,
the fact they didn't have full camp bear for each other.
Of course Connor is in full camp for all those so he's going to be in shape.
But strategically game plan wise and having those,
those fine motor skills prepared for stuffing that take down,
keeping the fight on the feet,
preparing for an orthodox wrestler,
he never saw.
So bet you he wasn't even working stuffing take dance.
Cause although that isn't a guy who takes you down,
well he certainly would work on it was working it.
Yeah.
Certainly level Brian Without fucking,
but that's not a huge part of your guys in practice.
They're not just gonna sit there like trying to take you down.
It's MMA and you're just not going to bring in strikers and bringing all sorts
of guys.
Yeah.
It's a good fight.
His,
his boy is a,
is a Nelson is boys Nelson Phenomena Jujitsu and very good to take down.
There's a lot to like about this fight a lot to a,
I liked this fight as much as I liked the Aldo fight,
if not more.
I really do because I've been wanting to see if you're right.
You're allowed to.
I've been wanting to see Conor fight a wrestler but not on a 12 week notice.
I don't want you to share.
It happened.
I do.
I've got a real problem.
Hey,
got to hear his coach and you're kind of swim coach and you know he's been taken
down.
You just tell him to keep standing up.
No Jujitsu.
Just keep standing up.
Keep trying to stand up.
What kind of strategy and a fucking old man can you,
can you just start with what do you ask him?
What you tell him?
It's Connor man.
He does his thing.
He,
you got to remember it.
He got taken down by Dennis Seaver.
I know people forget that he got taken down,
popped up,
but he got taken down like three or four times.
It's hard to pop up against Chapman.
Has He got taken down?
We probably didn't anticipate that it was going to turn into a wrestling match
at all.
And it was taken down by Dennis Eve.
Right?
Probably that's what worries me
was Chapman is no fucking joke dude.
Oh and,
and then,
but the problem is if I'm a betting man,
which I've been known to bed,
if I'm a betting man,
I think Chapman does Knox mountain the third round,
faking a takedown land and overhand.
That's what I think my,
my what my heart wants.
I want calm and go out there and win.
Why do you just Conor to win?
I want Connor week cause I like what he stands for and,
and when I met him,
he was just a natural,
genuinely good dude and he's beating the game.
I like people who beat the game.
He's a star.
He's the 1% of one percenters.
And he backs it up.
He's our Mohammed Ali to see a guy lose on a,
on a match up that he got on 12 days notice.
Again,
it's a completely different style.
I don't want to see him go out like that.
He's so excited.
He was out for a grip.
You got to remember he was in the UFC.
He lost,
he didn't come into the gym has coaching like,
Bro,
you don't come back in the gym man.
Just get outta here.
I don't want to see him go out and like that man.
He,
he has a chance to be great.
He still entertain to be our Lebron James,
but of course some horrible happens like this.
What happens to a man because that's not,
you think the UFC is fucking up.
You think the UFC should just postpone the fight?
I think it's a bad idea what they're doing or they shouldn't fight with your
mentors.
If I was his manager,
and I swear to God I said this on the podcast,
I,
I would,
I would tell him to fake a fucking injury and wait till October.
I really want you guys got to understand how much money has been spent on this
prime scan you're looking at.
You're looking at it very short.
Just like the Reebok deal,
very shortsighted,
quick buck this weekend.
In the grand scheme of things,
he has potential to be your biggest star of all time,
but let's give him the worst matchup.
[inaudible] on 12 days notice,
but,
and he just went through a whole camp.
Who knows if he's healthy,
but if he wins and he's the best,
that's the Ganzel
interim title.
Big Jose.
I'm coming for the other belt.
I've got the real bad.
I want to hear spit bucket and shine up my belt and bring it here to me.
If he wins.
Oh,
it pays off huge.
It's the fuck.
Yes.
Everyone knew
getting some questions about him,
man.
There's so many questions and that's what's exciting about the Mendez fight is
that it's to look for sure,
although was going to test them,
but men is going to fucking test him to in a different way.
For sure.
We need to find out whether or not they can use [inaudible] for this fight.
I'm just saying it's resident.
I'm saying it's rare.
You get a guy of his capabilities and we,
we,
we have something that could be great here.
His entertainment value 12 days is tough.
I just love his energy.
He makes me want to fight,
see the fight.
He's so exciting.
He's such a great shot and chat and I love chatting.
Everyone knows I love people that are listening.
Please let me know if you do know whether or not,
because we're not going to go with this waltz happened and please let me know if
you know whether or not they're going to be able to use ivs during this fight.
If they'd be able to use IVF after this Williams cause eventually it's going to
be giant.
And especially when you got a guy like Conor is cut in 27 towns,
where did you get that statistic about?
It takes seven days to fully recharge or a medic on an army medic on the set of
kingdom who is,
who is a restaurant college and he was,
he was talking about how he said the biggest problem with this ivy thing,
and this is just him.
Yeah,
I don't know if it's right,
but he said,
he said the biggest problem is that you can see a lot more traumatic brain
injury if guys aren't allowed to hydrate with Ivs and ideas.
It takes a long time to hydrate orally as opposed to with an IV.
And he said that to get fully hydrated where your cells are,
where they were before it takes up to seven days.
I don't know if that's the case,
but that's what Andy Foster said that a good percentage of fighters are fighting
dehydrated fruit.
Get into the octagon.
They're not your brain.
No,
not good for your.
A lot of time you see guys who weren't successful at one weight class,
they cut weight class and then their chin goes choose cause they're cutting a
lot of weight so you don't have that fluid in the brewery.
Dangerous.
Jimmy's got some information for us.
This,
okay,
first,
that means
UFC one 89 participants can expect to be a part of the new regime.
Oh,
oh my God,
so this one 89 they can't fucking rehydrate.
Let me ask you this.
How do they know if a guy rehydrates with electrolyte and fluid?
Well,
here's the problem.
How can you test that?
You can test,
you can test,
you can test for plastics,
plastics in the blood.
There's residue or you're talking about microscopic amounts of residue from the
plastic.
Now you're testing for fucking plastics.
Now you're testing for plastics,
which apparently the reason this all came out as the plastics can mask.
Apparently according to this medic,
the plastics themselves I guess can mask whether or not you've been blood doping
or there are similar compounds in there and it makes it harder to test and that
that's what I was interested in.
You might be true.
What I'd heard was that the plastics was how they test for blood doping because
if they,
if they test your blood and your blood has traces,
I was plastic and it means you might've taken bags of blood and put them back.
That doesn't hold water either though,
because then you could just say,
I was,
I was doing what everybody else does,
which is an ivy.
I was rehydrating Ivy.
You can't do it.
I'm saying before that.
Right.
So before that,
they didn't test for it before that this is the first time they've ever tested
for these plastics and because it was the first time they've had I ivs had been
used not just openly,
but I mean they'd talk about,
yes it does.
Yes.
It's healthier for the fucking fighters.
It's dangerous to not ivy.
Right,
but is it look book Bj Penn,
he says ivs are for wimps and he wrote Hashtag beer and hot dogs.
He's never sucked though.
Yes,
he has one 45 then Bj Penn is,
look at that.
He's not that tall.
Bj also fosters a different time though.
It's a little different now.
It's guys hard for long more weight than when,
uh,
I still say that the Bj Penn,
that fog Diego Sanchez was one of the best,
if not the best,
155 pounds that ever walked the fucking face of the planet.
I agree in,
didn't use an ivy.
I understand that.
Guess what?
Guess what Bj Penn walks around I not heavier than one 70,
from what I've seen.
No,
no,
you're right.
Let's just be smaller than Conor McGregor.
Yeah.
It's not a huge weight cut.
Any fought Liotta Machida at heavyweight saying is such a Badass.
Bj Penn,
such a legend,
one of the nicest guy ever.
Best.
He's awesome.
And unless you fuck with them,
fuck with them and go with them.
It's wrong to be with the fuck would I remember when Doug Davidoff and I met him
at this premiere.
Oh,
wait a minute.
The Ivy band,
somebody just tweeted me this.
The Ivy band has been pushed til October.
Oh,
snap.
Sung the back ivy band for UFC fighters until October.
Concerns over dangerous weight cuts and improper rehydration.
The short term have won out over the u s a DA's desire to get rid of ivy usage
fighters are now have a three month grace period to adjust.
Yeah.
There's an argument that they shouldn't do this.
I agree.
I'm not going to pay out of my you go pod or decal.
Thank you to Dan Worms.
Dan On Twitter for sending me that information.
Yeah.
This is um,
interesting times changing.
Interesting to the reason they postpone is what I heard is there's a lot of
pushback,
right?
Like lung fighters like Whoa,
this is too short notice man doctors as well,
including the UFC doctor who makes these rules.
People that have never fought or cut weight before really.
Exactly.
In the octagon,
but you can't do this.
Okay.
How many fights you've been in?
Shut your fucking mouth.
Yeah.
I don't know what they're thinking,
man.
With all this bringing these people in to,
I mean I guess the idea is to try to clean up the sport,
but for short,
short term,
it could be devastating.
Horribly devastating.
The thing is is to my understanding,
they say they test five,
five times out of out of competition.
Random lead.
Right now that's just five clients year five random guys a year.
Yeah.
That's not fun.
Every fighter's tested five times.
Every fighter's tested five times a year.
I don't think so.
I think it's five random.
No,
no,
no.
Every fight or fight,
every fighter on the roster is going to be tested five times randomly a year.
Are you sure?
Cause they told me otherwise.
Uh,
Dominick Cruz told me otherwise while Dominic may be right,
but I don't think he is.
Every fighter on Yoast.
Every fighter in the UFC roster tested five times a year,
which is ridiculous.
Yeah,
I think that's exactly it.
I,
but then that's what in Dominic's like,
no man,
it's five,
five fighters randomly.
That doesn't make any sense.
That's stupid.
They can test anyone.
Revamped UFC drug policy include,
here it is,
includes random year round testing,
two year suspension for first time offenders,
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo Doo,
Doo Doo.
Let's see,
a first offense.
Okay.
When are they going to test?
Or is it five telling me?
See,
I thought everyone is,
could be tested,
but they're not guaranteed.
Each individual tested five times throughout the year.
Yeah.
I don't know,
ma'am.
Let have any test that is so what?
There's 705 well,
that's the whole idea.
Uh,
yeah.
No,
every fight or five times a year,
man.
Yeah,
sure.
Save money on tests.
Give it to the fighters and sponsorship.
I got to take them.
No,
they're not going to save the money for the fighters.
Started to go to the chest,
randomly test all 500 athletes several times a year.
We're sending a message.
If you're cheating,
you'll get caught,
suspended and fine.
We want the sport to be clean.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
You know,
I don't know what to say.
It's all a I,
in a way,
I feel like science is,
they're not on the side of time and technological advancement and it's going to
be very tough because I feel like science is always gonna find a way to beat any
kind of test.
Testing is always behind.
I'm not saying it's an excuse,
but I'm just saying it's gonna be interesting to see how now scientists who are
involved in the fight game and fighters figure out a way around this testing
five times here.
Very difficult,
but something like,
well,
it'll be a battle between the cheaters and the detectors because the,
the science involved in detecting is getting better as well.
So it's weird,
man.
It's like this a battle between cheaters and an [inaudible] account.
Many guys like just just snuck under the wire and retired before it all ended in
college.
I would imagine a lot when you love to go change in their bodies.
Randy coture was in his forties and it was beating the shit if you,
when you a little bit to kind of look at his blood work.
When we got going on here,
Fella,
he kind of was,
he was kind of open about being on TRT I think later on somewhere,
right?
I don't believe he was.
I thought he was like,
I thought it was kind of known when he was 45 is doing some testosterone.
No,
no,
no.
I think it was all just speculation.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
but again,
I don't know how you'd do it without what Tatra training three times a day.
Wrestling,
kicking.
Good luck with [inaudible] to do bloodwork on Herschel Walker when Herschel
Walker was 48 and he fought in Strikeforce and was built like a brick shit house
freak though.
He's such an uh,
a 1% or for so long in the NFL before in college they were like,
what?
He's a 1% or of 1% and 45 with world class speed outlier.
Total out.
Just like a Bo Jackson.
Yeah,
exactly.
Anything like that.
Yeah.
Every now and then you'll get one of those dudes didn't even lift,
just had crazy regimen exercise regimen,
but just body weight stuff and a thousand pushups a day,
a thousand sit ups a day.
Weird,
weird stuff.
It was a religion for him.
He never went out and drank.
He had,
they did a really interesting profile on him.
Well there was other guys that were like that too.
I mean there's,
there's always a few guys that just,
we'll work harder than anybody else on top of the fact that they're just
absolute freak athletes.
And that's like a Herschel Walker Brian,
same way.
Nobody has his work ethic.
It's weird.
His work at Toby Bryant?
Yeah.
Oh,
the craziest thing in the world.
Nothing better.
Michael Jordan and Floyd Mayweather.
Floyd Mayweather is so obsessed with training.
He'll wake up at three in the morning and make everybody come to the gym,
come home and be to show his wife just read thing.
I mean it's ridiculous man.
This training was more of a choker.
No,
no,
he doesn't like EFC hits her on top of the head.
So you can't see.
That's interesting because you have to shave her head to prove the weld cheese
as well.
That's smart.
Jesus.
He's
smart.
You know what you do?
You open hand loans.
Well,
I'm going to give advice.
What's that?
What's that movie Travis Browne Song.
People listen.
Do what
now?
Now do I hit him with the liver or nobody?
Pullovers husbands like keep going,
Joe,
to remember that during that movie,
the grifters,
when the guys takes out a pillowcase and he starts putting oranges in pillowcase
and he goes,
you know what,
I'm doing this and Angelica Houston does.
She can hit me.
When you hit somebody with it,
pillowcase with aren't just test.
It doesn't create any PR PR who sees and she knows he's going to take a
pillowcase with RMG.
That's true.
That's the movies.
Okay for the Lord has taken you in the facial.
Y'All fuck yeah,
you're going to blind eyes would be swollen.
She's going to hit her in the body.
And I remember going,
God damn,
that's terrible.
[inaudible] who wrote a movie?
Obey man's never beaten guys standing ivy.
Awful.
I was like,
that's how horrible a pillow case with art just,
and I'm gonna beat the fuck out of you with it.
It's like the woman who killed a man would be frozen with frozen leg lamb,
a lamb of a leg of lamb.
So she took out a frozen leg of lamb,
bashed him in the fucking head,
and then cooked it and ate it.
Fed Her.
And her kids,
you know,
he was a,
I think apparently he was at the table and she took it and just crack them in
the back of the head and bludgeoned to death with a leg of lamb and then cooked
it.
And where this happened,
it's a long time ago.
I think it was an econ was nothing.
Yeah,
England,
England.
That's fun.
He'd say Scotland.
Yeah.
He says crazy,
right?
People killed people with everything.
Come up with all kinds of boards.
Sure.
People kill people.
You can think of it.
It's happened.
Do you want to get rid of the body?
That's why that they,
they say the mafia is to Fiji to pigs because they'll eat everything coming
ahead.
Does that Mexican cartel guy,
I forget the name for it,
but in Spanish it means,
uh,
like Porch Stu.
Cause he would have this vat,
we'd put the bodies in.
Well acid,
they use acid.
That's a true,
they talked about this guy who,
he was involved in horse racing.
They turned out to be a member of the Zetas cartel or what was that?
Remember that those guys were really all but one of them for sure.
And he used to,
he was a big and the horse racing thing and one of the testimonies was that the
guy,
he brought him out to talk to them cause they were just a little suspicious.
And another guy was walked out and he had a blindfold on and they just shot him.
They do a Holler if is that.
We had to do boom shot him and put him in acid and they go look,
so we want to talk to you.
Sorry about that.
And the guy starts throwing up,
you know,
and just terrified and goes,
sorry,
we as in nasty business.
But anyways,
he's gone now just boiling away and acid just disappearing.
And he goes,
so we had to talk.
There's a rumor apparently that you're talking to cops.
I know that's not true personally.
I know.
I just wanted you to know that.
I know it's not true anyway.
You want some,
you want to grab a beer.
That's,
that's how,
that's how they would kind of let you know.
By the way,
that if there's any question,
you'll be in that Vat.
Oh,
acid.
Yeah.
You might want to start planning your trip to Costa Rica.
You might want to fucking get some fucking plane ticket to Canada when the,
when the feds come to talk to you and they say they're going to protect you,
you might want it.
Finland's a good spot fuck out of him.
I mean,
how much easier was it to get away with crime back in the day then?
Now,
man,
Oh man,
I can't do shit now.
You can do anything.
They didn't even have technology.
Yeah,
man.
And that fingerprint.
I was watching a documentary on the mobsters,
like the American mob,
which started in New York and all those guys,
and you look at the whole setup they had.
It's like,
God,
these days you're not doing that.
You know what,
man?
I talked to somebody,
I talked to some Philly detectives,
like to longtime veteran detectives in Philadelphia.
I spent a lot of time with him and I said,
Oh,
you know,
he said,
we don't rely,
you'd be amazed at how we don't rely.
A lot of times on forensics and fingerprints.
He said,
when you're investigating a murder,
they were homicide in Texas.
He said,
when you're investigating a murder,
you have to realize most people confess.
Once you get them in questioning,
that you're,
what you're dealing with is they know in their hearts they've been raised.
Even if you're a sociopath,
you've been raised from a very young age to believe this,
to know that this is the ultimate crime.
You took another life.
And by the time you get them in there and you know how to properly interrogate
somebody and really ask them questions and more importantly,
get them on your side.
Just go listen dude.
Listen.
Everybody does crazy shit.
Once in a while there's a Radiolab podcast about that guy that was a very
prolific serial killer in the Pacific northwest with the river killer,
was a green,
green river killer and Seattle,
I think he was,
uh,
he was,
committing necrophilia yeah.
On a lot of these girls and they had to get them to admit it.
So they talked to this guy and the guy who was the interrogator,
he talked to him for six months.
Every day he would sit down with this guy for six months.
They were trying to figure out what the fuck the guy did.
And then slowly but surely over the course of this six months,
the dude's slowly started admitting all the different things that he did and
admitted why he did it and admitted he did it just because he enjoyed it for a
while.
You know,
he tried to say that the girl pissed him off and this thing goes,
did you enter into this knowing that she could make you upset and that you would
wind up killing her?
And he goes,
yes.
Yeah,
I did.
Well,
why'd you do it?
Cause I just,
I had to do it.
How to kill Richard.
Richard Walter,
who's an incredible profile or said they,
I think it was like the green river killer,
but the guy was clearly killing women and he said to the cops,
he said,
just just put a stake out at this site.
You will find him in his car.
He will be jerking off.
You'll find him.
He'll come back to the site and he masturbates here and thinks about what he
did.
Sure enough,
that's how they caught him.
They see,
they see a guy jerking off his car looking down right down where he buried the
body jacket.
Hi Buddy.
Want to talk to you?
Yeah.
What are you doing?
We know,
and then they come in and that's,
there are,
there are behaviors.
This book,
the murder room is so fucking incredible.
This guy,
Richard Walter,
there are behaviors that people do like certain guys will rape and kill a woman,
but when they're raping her,
if she dies in the process,
they'll stop immediately because they don't want the cops to think they're
freaks.
All kinds of weird shit like that.
That was the thing of what this green river guys,
and he didn't want them to know that he fucked them after they were.
That's right.
He didn't want to admit it because he had an ego and ego and the guy in the way
he got them to do it.
He goes,
look,
you wouldn't be the first guy.
A lot of guys who've done that's right.
He's like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
he will tell you I actually,
I did do that and I didn't do that.
They used to,
they got a guy,
I'm a high level terrorist who had never seen porn and they started showing him
porn.
Oh.
And I said,
and he,
it was like the carrot and the stick and he was like,
Hey,
do you want to see more of this?
We'll show you what the hell she tellers scene.
And he started talking just to see it.
No,
he was a,
he became up in a very strict Islamic society.
So there's showed them some dicks.
Lucky.
Do you want to know these really hot girls?
You
can
let me tell you something man.
Bella,
Donna and I said,
Carol,
we'll get you talking if you have a stone and we'll get you throwing up.
But she puts that baseball bat up.
Arrest [inaudible] Fossa.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll freaking tell you whatever you want on the podcast.
She was fucking great.
I said Karen.
Yeah,
she was cool.
Smart.
She cool.
Shoot when you went like this?
No,
no.
She's all right.
Smart wouldn't go with fucking great greats in 10th grade.
Might be a little intense to be a little hyperbole there.
May never seen one of our parents.
How about that?
Fuck,
haven't I didn't,
man.
I swear to God.
I have never seen her.
Not One.
You'd never seen her work?
Did Not do research for that episode.
Yeah.
Well I know she's,
I went,
yeah,
she does some heavy shit to almost too much where you go,
okay,
well that can't be on my podcast.
She said her skin was bad because she was taken in her and Tom said,
I think you're taking in too much testosterone.
Too many loads.
Yeah.
She's scratching a,
you got a whore on your hands.
You imagine if you take it,
somebody loads it.
It changes your biological profile.
Imagine if you're just dating a girl.
She had cut my fucking face.
Keeps breaking out.
What's happening?
These fucking guys busting all over my face,
man.
In her.
You're in just so much come in her body probably annually.
A lot of it and go,
oh,
that doesn't make that noise when I'm coming,
unless I'm fighting.
Yeah.
I've never had that noise because there's some hot about that though.
I would agree with you with asa.
I agree.
I like a turbo slot.
Most contact offset and have her print up that shirt with glitter.
I'll,
I'll make you a shirt.
Awesome.
Hashtag [inaudible] why don't we make them?
I'll wear turbans.
Fuck yeah.
No it's not.
Hey,
we're this take turbo slept.
I guarantee you if you guys put out a turbo sweat shirt fell out and give her
the girl limited edition for women.
You don't have a balls.
I say dude,
you can fucking limited edition.
Just make 20 they'll sell instantly.
Zach,
when he tweaks we get now about turbo turbo slit.
Sure Dave will terrible.
So it's a great great word.
Brings Funny Tourville Slash sled or is it just turbo?
Turbo slow.
It's a great designation.
Is it one word or two words?
Two words I guess.
Terrible schools do hashtag turbo slash hashtag turbo slot.
Oh Turbo slut that's going like anything that happens in the news now from now
on,
Hashtag turbos for little slap.
Anytime a girl does something fucked up,
it's going to be attack turbo sled girl cheese on a man
can work for guys to make that t shirt on.
Ag Turbo slut.
I like it for girls.
We don't have any women.
We don't know.
That's more of a tea a day.
You think so?
Tank top.
What girls get away material size guys will buy it for their girl.
You don't think awesome would wear it?
Yeah.
Okay.
We got one sale
making money.
Every girl in suicide,
those suicide girls talk cash doctor,
we'll slot.
I guarantee Whitney just for shits and giggles.
Whitney Cummings with when we're hitting you would not wear that.
She'd be,
I said jokes with me with now she's more of a feminist
cause it's funny and say I disagree.
All right.
And I'm talking for her.
She'd probably be like,
shut up dude.
I don't know if it works.
Listen man,
I'll wear that.
How about we sell it on [inaudible] dot com all right,
we'll figure it out.
No problem.
Turbo slat gay defect,
Gay Dicom.
I like our website.
T fat.
Kay.
Yeah.
Well,
you guys have a great fucking show.
I'll tell you that.
I love your podcast.
I'm so happy that you guys are doing it.
It's so cool to see so many people that have great podcasts now.
This isn't the best times ever for like listening to shit.
Dude,
I'm not mirror and had the president of the United States in his garage in that
crazy shit,
man.
That's weird,
crazy counselor crowd as a podcast.
I was like,
fuck yeah,
man.
It's really weird,
right?
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's like,
wow,
this is,
these are weird,
man.
That's a,
that's an interview you're prepared for.
He wasn't,
you could tell he was nervous.
Oh,
well how do you not be?
No,
I'm just saying you could get like,
yeah,
for sure.
It's in his garage,
leader of the free world,
but he has,
he has a,
Obama said,
you know,
do you get nervous to do this stuff?
Obama basically was like,
I'm in your garage.
I'm not getting nervous.
I've talked to bigger crowds when he did a garage.
I did between two ferns,
Zach Galifianakis.
I was a man.
He did and he was funny.
He,
yes,
yes.
And he was really funny.
Wow,
this is awesome.
Yeah,
it's actually always been the funniest dude you said on a recent podcast that
you think Kevin Hart's the biggest comedian ever all time.
Yeah.
I think he's the biggest in the United States.
Big to Eddie Murphy.
Yeah.
Oh,
definitely.
Definitely.
He is.
He's bigger and bigger as far as like what he could do,
like arenas and stuff like that.
But Russell Peters is the biggest internationally,
so it's like Kevin Hart is the biggest in America,
but Russell Peters sells out the o two arena.
Yeah,
he's getting,
he's great.
And Russell is just a great guy.
Russell hosted last night at the Ice House in Pasadena.
That's how humble I show it.
The Ice House.
I called him and I asked her if you want to do it.
He goes,
yeah,
fuck yeah.
He goes,
can I host?
And I'm like,
you can do whatever you want,
so hum.
You fucked my wife.
Like you can take a shower,
do whatever you want.
Man.
You're Russell Peters,
truly humble and he's such a funny dude.
Give me a Breitling.
Wow.
Damn Bro.
Watch just for the hell it to me.
He had it on.
I go,
that's a sweet Raj.
He goes,
takes it off and he puts it on me.
I go,
I can't take your watch.
And he goes,
come on and take my fucking watch dance the best.
Was he the coolest guy ever?
Yeah,
he is one of the nicest human beings I've ever met.
Her met life,
couldn't be more supportive of comics,
couldn't be more generous with like taking guys in the road with them promoting
guys because some guys out,
everything about them is great and that's one of the reasons why it's so
successful.
It's a fight game.
Jujitsu,
boxing,
you think he's bigger than Kevin Hart?
Internationally International,
yes,
but Kevin Hart's bigger in the United States.
He's so big.
Kevin Hart is so talented for me.
Like I,
he's one of these guys,
I've worked with him twice and he makes me laugh.
He's always making people laugh.
He's very,
very funny.
But another generous guy,
very generous.
It's super motivated,
like crazy work ethic,
right?
Oh,
I love his work ethic.
I would go with his Instagram.
He's always working out and do it.
All kinds of crazy shit.
He,
he's,
he's got an Instagram once.
He's like in the trailer,
it's like five o'clock in the morning.
They already been to the gym,
be fucking flew in from another state.
He's worth,
he did a concert last night in front of like fucking 30,000 people.
Now he's on the movie set all the other people in his trailer or fallen asleep
and he's like,
look around.
Look at my trainer.
My trainer has fallen asleep
to a lifestyle for everybody,
but he's a bad,
never stops.
He never stops writing.
The one thing that I've seen,
especially with Comedians,
a lot of you guys,
all,
you guys have crazy work ethics.
I feel like if you have to be,
yeah.
You have to choose you this day and age,
right?
To create material.
Yeah.
To,
to create new material all the time.
Gone through that.
You have to,
you have to constantly be on stage.
You have to constantly be writing.
You have to constantly be thinking,
Madison Square Garden.
He's sold out three shows.
Dude.
Get the fuck Outta here,
man.
Serves it.
We're making history people.
Massive Square Garden sold out.
Three,
look at the audience like he's,
he's a comedic scroll down so you could see that better.
Scroll the call like with a gold Mike.
They won't let you scroll down the mall.
No Damn.
Look at this.
Oh,
that's it.
That's the image.
That's insane.
He's got a gold Mike.
Oh my God.
What's it called?
Micro mother fucker.
Who uses a gold microphone.
That's why not.
Why wouldn't they?
Why would you want a silver one?
He's always been,
he's such a generous person.
He's such a good guy.
Well,
I'm eight.
I told you I met him.
We was with his kids and his girlfriend wants.
I ran into him.
He was like,
it couldn't be friendlier.
I'd never met him before,
but I met him.
He immediately gives me a giant hug.
Super price could have been almost as big as him if certain things would of went
its way.
Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle at the time was fucking gay.
He still could be.
He still could be if you want it to.
Dave Chappelle's d yeah,
absolutely.
Dave Chappelle's is different at different animals,
different animals.
Dave Chappelle likes to show up with a fucking microphone and a speaker and do a
show in a park like he's done since he was 17 he's a monster.
He's a very,
very,
very funny man.
Super talented.
And he's still in his show.
The Chappelle show was huge and then he just disappeared.
Right?
Cause he didn't like the way things were going.
Well they down to get him to listen to them and do their,
show him their way and they wanted him to stop saying the n word.
There was all sorts of shit was going on.
They were,
you know,
they had a big DVD deal on the table.
There was like $50 million and he was like,
you know what,
I'm going to do whatever I want to do,
so fuck off.
And just went to Africa.
You know,
I think both his parents are professors,
aren't they?
I don't know.
But I know,
you know,
still to this day he's doing great.
You know,
it's not sure,
but he,
he's not the guy like on his own time,
Kevin Hart,
guy smoked cigarettes,
he believes in conspiracy theories.
Like he works out a little bit but he's not the kind of healthy that Hart Kevin
Hart
is like,
he's going to be like Oprah.
I watched Kevin Hart wrestle with Laurence Fishburne.
They,
we shot the scene where he was,
he had to basically have a fight with you want to talk about athletic and
explosive.
He might be five,
four but I've never,
he was,
we were all going look it out fucking fast.
He moves and he was doing a comedically like gone under his legs and Lawrence is
a big guy and it was just like,
I was kind of taken aback with just how long he was able to keep that shit up.
Doing his own stunts,
jumping through the hair.
[inaudible] exit fucking fit man.
Well here's videos who puts on Instagram of him working on every morning and he
does crazy shit.
Like which lines she would ditch the workout gloves though.
He's loves to workout clothes,
but the a lot of guys don't want to have had when he squats like Bro.
Oh really?
Hey Man.
It's tough man.
A lot of guys don't everything again though.
You know it's not a prolapse that take it easy.
Just say you want to use a bar,
a bar on your big back had,
did you say pad?
I'm a boss.
I mean a pad.
A pad.
You don't use a patent on the bar and she's never really sun.
You put that fucking bar and your back and just squat.
Can't do that man.
You like get,
yeah,
you just can't do that.
It's not loud man.
The fuck up Brian counts dude.
I use gloves on.
Do you phone?
I don't use Chyna.
I don't use gloves.
I should maybe cause I do a lot more
oil.
You guys.
I'm on.
I dead lift though.
It dead lift without.
I'm going to use gloves from the dead.
Are raised as you saw yesterday.
Yes I did.
Did you get hit in the head?
I was probably somebody who wasn't,
wasn't mobile and get,
I didn't get hidden that you didn't get hit once.
Now I have a hard time.
Barb Wayne the night did it before and Wayne did hit me in my face once with
Sparta guy.
So shitty.
He didn't land one shot.
He a Jones jr bully Travis Browne.
He's,
he probably is not the most athletic guy.
That's correct.
And so I did not get who use barring whoever guy counting Wayne puts me in with
their different dudes and that,
you know,
and you swore the shit guy from million dollar baby,
I don't want to talk badly.
I'm good.
If you don't mind.
Can you give a touch?
She's keeping it.
No,
he did not.
Can You keep your references?
So next time you saw him you need to say,
Hey,
I'm gonna go beat this kid.
I've been spine with Wayne who,
you know,
and he was fine with what,
I know that I'm just saying that he throws punches at me and I'm learning how to
move and explaining to the guy who was not call a multiple time world boxing
champion.
One of the great men,
I,
one of my favorite people in the world.
And I trained with him all the time because I chance I get to train with them
and he'll,
he teaches me the way you're probably supposed to teach,
which is he'll throw shots at me,
not full obviously,
but you learn a little bit of how to move if you're working with a guy that good
and then you get it with a guy who is not good,
you're gonna be able to move a little better.
And you see that he's involved in that semi colon thing where you get tattooed
like a semi colon on your arm to like to say,
to let you know that like,
life's not over.
There's more to go.
I don't know the story.
I talked to him about that depression movement thing.
Well,
I'm not,
well,
he dealt with some stuff.
I don't know how vocal he is,
but I know being a fighter and having 350 fights mean he,
maybe he
had,
I don't want to speak out of turn,
but I know,
uh,
he's been maybe involved in some of that stuff.
Um,
but anyway,
so they get these tattoos and say they beat depression dot with a comma on it,
you know,
semi-colon.
Yeah.
Which indicates there's more to come in the sentence like you don't end a
sentence with that.
There's more to come.
You know,
it's absolutely dumb about that.
But he's just one of those guys.
Instagram.
Okay.
Yeah.
So he's one of those dudes.
I love being around because he's just such a humble motherfucker.
Such a nice guy and,
and it's like you're going to teach me and he really like,
he really like no matter when,
where he's always there,
always present and just such a fucking amazing,
I'm Gregor loves,
I gave him a hug on his way to the aisle.
Oh yeah.
I can send her out.
He's a legend in Ireland.
Super Legend Rock.
Him and Barry McGuigan are the two biggest boxers from Ireland.
Pretty much.
Everyone's well,
I'm,
I like,
I'm always so flattered that I even get to train with someone like that.
Yeah,
but you said it's bar with them.
Well,
what I'm saying is that he'll move around and punch me,
punch me in the face if I don't have my hands up,
what we do,
spar,
he puts on headgear and he puts on her own name will go,
you know,
and,
and you know,
he's not opening up on me.
He's not trying to kill you,
but he goes hit.
But you learn.
And when you do that with someone like that,
and then you go with somebody who's not,
you know,
close to that you can get out of the way.
But do you,
do you have any concern whatsoever about getting punched in the head or just
because I'm not taking it on my chicken.
I'm not getting punched in the problem.
But you don't even when Wayne hits you,
that's,
that counts my man.
It's worth it to me.
It's worth it.
Yeah.
I love,
I love boxing and I love the feeling,
you know,
it was bars a lot.
Lucy Kay.
Really?
Yeah,
we had a conversation about it.
He goes,
I love it.
I just love it.
I love doing it.
But a guys who guys who done also may not be getting again like it's one thing
to get really hit if you get even a good jab and you got a big headache.
And that's what I avoid.
Cause if you're fighting like rocky at the gym who fights a lot and now that kid
can really hit well and if you well for me,
why is that 185 pounds?
He was like this,
the thrill is to look,
he loves the thrill,
loves the thrill of sparring.
I just don't get it.
If you're making money off your brain,
I don't get why you would cause he's not just a language and learning.
It's really hard to,
it hasn't been a detriment.
Yeah.
And so he's willing to take the chance for the thrill.
I like it cause it's so hard.
I like it because it's close to impossible for to be bold.
The,
the feeling of being alive and taking any kind of risk and problem solving in a
very like Gary,
you get it.
You know what I mean?
That's for me what it is,
problem solving and learning patterns.
And,
and seeing it actually works sometimes charges you up.
Like it makes you excited about doing other shit because of that,
you know,
for a lot of fun.
Peaceful.
Yeah.
100%.
For you,
it's different because like you were,
first of all,
at the highest level there is professional UFC and you're sparring with guys
like Shane car,
which is not even a little bit fun.
I can't even imagine that.
I can't imagine you couldn't pay me to go to a boxing gym right now.
I'll do Jujitsu.
But if you said,
Hey Brendan,
come down here and let's box.
Yeah,
shout out to box and burn though.
Copay number one gym in California.
According to men's fitness,
Tony Jeffries and women call it.
Ooh.
Do you guys want to learn boxing?
Ooh,
great place to work out.
Hey,
uh,
let's wrap this up cause I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
All right,
so a big fucking fight this weekend.
Huge fights can be fun.
Come see me.
Pick your,
pick what happens
on the main event.
Mendez Mcgregor.
Come on,
son.
If I'm betting money,
I'm taking Mendez.
My heart says Conor,
Brian Killen I got,
I got Conor Mcgregor.
Really?
I do.
I think he hits harder than than than people know and realize and can connect.
I think it's going to connect.
I think it's bigger.
It's a different kind of fighter for Chad Mendez.
I think he's going to,
it's,
I hope you're right.
We have,
we actually have a bet on it.
What do teachers sales of July.
That's right.
We had a whole month of tee shirts.
That's no pump.
That's the month I'm going to start Instagram in it.
We don't,
we don't drop turbo slot until August to just promise me that knows next week.
So come on man.
It was my idea of a sudden terrible sluts going to be a big seller.
See the conversation was turbo sluts really not worth doing
Hashtag [inaudible] slide,
but that has a shirt hashtag terrible slut.
I think Daryl Sal simple.
Keep it simple.
I'm excited about is I,
but I'd never grow up and it's Peter Pan that looks like Brian Callan.
So fine.
The kid on the back.
I like that.
And then we have done,
we have a big brown master,
Kim t dropping.
No,
no big brown bear.
Big Brown star on our song.
Did you,
um,
who do you have in this fight?
Can you say?
Um,
I would say if I,
if I really had an inclination.
Okay.
I don't know.
What about Rory Robbie?
Um,
how bad does that fight get overlooked since salt cone or very bad.
It's crazy.
It's really,
it's really a shame because I love that it's just good to fight.
They're going to get a piece of the paper view so they're going to bear a fit
anyway.
But I think that Rory Macdonald and Robbie Lawler is a very fucking tough fight
to call.
We talked with Shannon,
I don't know what the fuck's going to happen and I don't know what the fuck's
gonna happen in the main event either.
I don't have an opinion on either.
That's why it's so exciting.
I don't know.
But I know that it's a biggest challenge.
Connor's ever faced hands.
But that's what we were saying before.
He fought Poria and he knocked it out for you in the first round and then does
this man Mendez and I love Porsche,
but men does is a far cry from port.
Are we doing in the fight?
Fight companions?
Yes.
Right.
You guys going to do a flight companion without me and my studio right next
Saturday.
[inaudible] exciting.
I'm excited.
I like it.
I like this one without the man.
Eddie Bravo going to do it.
If you talked to him,
he's supposed to get back to me.
I said I,
I said,
hey man,
we're going to companion and he goes without Rogan.
That's crazy.
I mean,
if you're scared,
I get it.
[inaudible] fighter and the kid would come see me,
the website,
t fat k.com t f a t k.com the fighter and the kid.com fighter and the kid on
iTunes.
Brian Callin on Twitter with a y because y in Denver next weekend,
July 16th 17th 18th at comedy works downtown and he's with me in Chicago.
Chicago theater.
Good googly Mowgli.
Chicago,
Brendan Schaub on Twitter and Instagram as well.
All right,
the Fox.
We love
the fuck out of you and we'll see you soon.
Much love everybody's.
That's good.